greetings to podcastville uncle joey
here this podcast is brought to you by
naturebox what do you do when you want a
snack but all you can find is junk food
you rely on your self-control to resist
the temptation and how do you end up
there you eat the junk food start
snacking healthy with nature bucks these
snacks are tremendous and right now
you'll save even more because nature box
is offering our church family 50 off
your first order when you go to
naturebox.com
joey again that's
naturebox.com slash joey the 50 off your
first order number two
here's something to chew on many recent
studies suggest
that having good oral health
impacts your overall health yet most of
us don't brush our teeth properly
you can start brushing better you know
why today
because right now you go to quip.com
joey and get your first refill pack for
free with equipped electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
quip dot com slash joey that's
quipped.com slash joey the new way to
brush your teeth and number three
father's day is coming
you see him sitting there he sits there
all day what do you think when he
happens when he sits there all day i
mean your dad's a nice guy in the whole
thing but his ass for men's like the
rest of us just cause he's your dad
don't mean his ass don't stink like 10
dead billy goats that ends today because
you're going to order hellotushy.com
joey what's hellotushie.com how's my
dad's ass gonna stink differently you
know how
hellotushy.com is a new portable bidet
which you could install on any toilet
you understand me and it works
tremendously it's got a 90-day
money-back guarantee and let me tell you
something there's nothing like getting
your [ __ ] washed with a little mist
two three times a day you avoid bacteria
you avoid hemorrhoids you avoid swamp
ass and now the sun is coming you know
what humidity does to your [ __ ]
right or wrong you ever take a [ __ ] in
the morning and you leave the house and
you walk around you mingle but meanwhile
your [ __ ] is on fire you don't know
why your [ __ ] little muffler is
burning you know why because you got
that [ __ ] backup drip no more
hellotushy.com will take care of that go
to hellotushy.com right now and press in
church church and get 10 off
hellotushy.com
hit it
oh [ __ ]
wednesday june 7th
are you kidding me or what
i'm feeling [ __ ] in minnesota
but look in california you follow me
church of what's happening now
lee syed
brodie stevens the master
the prince of periscope
that's what they call blp
yes
or pop no i'm sorry p.o.p
the prince of periscope you follow me
well don't give us a [ __ ] it's a church
of what's happened now [ __ ] lisa
and your [ __ ] uncle joey bam
bam
kick this mule lee they gotta hear the
powers shank me
feel this power cop suckers
yes
are you kidding me or what
kick this mule lee kick this mule
[ __ ] i want them to feel these
drums and [ __ ]
what
down
it's too much it's too much
it's too much i'm not gonna let a ten
dollar bag of chichi body i'm saying
what's going on brody stevens hey
brother excited to be here joey feeling
good you were down in palm springs
getting some sun yeah sunny hot down
there now how much warmer is it down
there than up here
today it was a lot you know it was about
104 out there when i left
yeah and the dodger game they played
this afternoon it was like a marine
layer it was like 70 degrees i thought
it was going to be smoking hot here too
but no it wasn't no no no tonight you'll
go out
you can't [ __ ] around this time of the
year here you leave your house with a
t-shirt you go somewhere warm you walk
out it's [ __ ] freezing yeah it gets
cold desert air comes in with the snakes
and the coyotes and [ __ ] you know
you know palm springs is just the cut
off the mountains it's like that's the
first spot
the
that the clouds from l.a don't get to it
cuts it off and it's just that's where
the heat starts out there in that desert
and that's the great thing about la
growing up here at night
you got the marine layer you got the
ocean breeze coming in so you go to a
dodger game you're going to wear a
jacket you go to anaheim stadium
it's cold down there at night that
stadium they've got wind coming through
there same thing with san diego at night
it it's always got san francis geez all
the cities are cold san francisco
san francisco
l.a but you think la and anaheim san
diego oh it's it's mild it gets cold at
night down there i've been to a few
dodger games when you go in like in
september
you go in there with a t-shirt at night
you're like wait a second i gotta walk
to my [ __ ] color
oh yeah reason out here what the [ __ ]
mistake do that make but who would have
figured it out yeah it gets cold but
we're lucky we're not in chicago you
know it rains hot you really gotta read
the the weather there and they're you
know they're not
we only get two bad weeks of weather
here
and they're in august the last two weeks
of august it gets a little on the human
side yeah but beside that this is a
great place weather-wise to live
i knew at the age of
12 that i couldn't deal with humidity i
didn't really understand that i knew
that it was something that when i came
out of the shower i was sweating
when i comb my hair i was sweating even
though i dried my shirt and my back and
my chest
when i was putting a t-shirt on
i felt this mist of water and then i
would walk
to these parties and by the time i got
there
my [ __ ] head would be [ __ ] up
all frizzed up i had the jew frog
growing up
and uh i just hated it and i didn't
really know the difference was that i
went to colorado the first time and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
this is what it feels like
not to have humidity in the air this is
what i want from now on
that's funny because
i left new york not for the cold i left
for the summer it was see i could deal
with humidity outside i could deal with
it going down the subway even though
that was really brutal but you get on
that subway with that air conditioning
and it felt good
my apartment
i didn't have air conditioning i had a
fan and a water bottle you know that's
what i had so it was pretty
brutal and then when i but i did it
after three years of living in in new
york i got it out of my system i did it
did the subway did the you know subway
to the bus because the subway was not
working
but you got to see a lot of different
people you know doing comedy down there
out there and you got to take the subway
you know i did it you i mean you're the
one who told me to go to new york it was
funny like you mentioned colorado right
here that's where my mom was living with
her boyfriend so i actually went to
colorado for a little bit i got to get
out of new york went to colorado
caught my breath and then i moved back
to la 2000 that was kind of my plan
anyway to be back here in la in 2000. i
had to you know like i mentioned
or i mentioned on the periscope how
you know i did an open mic here i
started here in la i went on stage at
you know i did one open mic in
chatsworth and i did that i did a comedy
workshop at
ucla i needed that and i had my we had
our graduation class
at the comedy store and i did well back
in
it was 93
and then i did one open i felt like uh
you know i did well it was a sunday
night it was packed bringing in five
friends you know one of those deals
sandy seashore it was paulie's sister
and the comedy store
i grew up with it meaning like i saw it
with my eyes
because my mom's boyfriend lived on
halloway up in a high rise so i could
see the comedy source sunset strip and
you could feel that energy and i wasn't
like a big crazy
you know comedy guy but i feel that
energy of the sunset strip but i would
also see the lights of dodger stadium it
was just there's something about seeing
the lights of dodger stadium no knowing
that there's a game going on there
there's a whole community going on there
you see the lights and then yeah you
know you can watch it on tv you can you
can listen on the radio but whenever i
drive by a stadium the rose bowl i
always look at it i have to make eye
contact with the sign dodger stadium i
have to see the lights if i'm going on
the 110
i've got to see the coliseum i have to
make eye contact i've never seen you for
growing up here when you told me that my
[ __ ] head exploded after like three
months after i met you
i would look at you and say this lunatic
from chicago or
well people thought i was from new york
or new york growing up here they were
maybe florida you were out of your
[ __ ] mind i don't know but yeah
growing up here i grew up here you know
in the valley
high school here you know you said your
dad went to school in north highway yeah
north hollywood high right here down the
street i wonder if yum yum donuts was
there back then
how long has that been there for
i want to know
i don't know that's an active corner you
got two high schools there you got a
rich kid what's the other high school
there oakwood right next to north
hollywood high yeah oh that's the one in
the middle of the school other block
yeah well it's on magnolia it's on the
other side it's between oakwood and
north hollywood oakwood's private
rich kids probably
yeah they have a like a full-time
staff of crossing guards on magnolia
throughout the day like six six
uh crosswalks down
you don't see them they have like
umbrellas okay so the school down the
block
towards the 101. right that's so good
they built a bridge right they just
stole the bridge now it costs like 30
thousand a year to go to that school and
you call your teacher by the first name
yeah it's progressive there's probably
like a petting zoo in the back yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah big wheels
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
that stuff is uh
i mean that's what i try and share on
twitter
i went to those private schools i grew
my mom yeah for a semester and i knew it
wasn't right which one did you go to i
went to like uh
probably like valley there was i think
it was actually called the valley school
over on like haskell and sherman way you
know the petting zoo notre dame
uh the other one on riverside
notre dame's on riverside that's high
school that's respected number one
baseball player prospect in the country
right now throws a hundred really tyler
green i believe is it tyler green yeah
kit throws a hundred and twelve schools
of 25 to 30 g's a year yeah a lot of
money now the problem with those schools
is you're going to school with denzel's
kids and
you know you're going to school with all
these people's kids right see
it's it's i don't know i don't know if
i'm i don't know campbell hall that's
another one campbell hall that's the big
one yeah these kids you know they're
rich kids they got helicopter parents so
they're doing they're doing you know
some
of the drugs i gotta tell you what
happened today that's right
that's right my head almost blew up this
morning
that's right talking about [ __ ] kids
very casually
i wake up i clean the cat little boxes i
feed the cats i make a little coffee
i smoke some dope the doorbell rings i'm
like little [ __ ] knocking on my door
today in the morning
or which water and that's who comes in
twice a week to help
with mercy in the daytime and [ __ ] while
my wife runs errands and [ __ ] and she
clean it's like a one what's going on
she goes i'm gonna come here today
instead of monday
it was news to me so i said well let me
finish up in the office
let me jump in the shower and i'll get
the [ __ ] out of here
i didn't feel like eating eggs so i just
had cereal at the house little
cornflakes never killed nobody that's
right i figured i'd disappear for two
hours right a little bit and come back
have a protein shake and go to jiu jitsu
that was my plan
i get down to the coffee place i get my
little usual green tea and i sit there
and i sit outside right and then i
just wanted to tighten up a bed i tried
to write a little story and these kids
sit next to me i don't count them with a
couple kids with a couple of young girls
i knew one of the girls
her name is rose
because one day me and uh [ __ ] were
down there burke chrysler
and she was there she asked us if we had
a lighter
and you know i got a two-year-old at the
time i said how old are you
and she's telling me she's 17.
look out and her dad's a big [ __ ]
publisher like a music publisher
so i've always known i always say hello
to a uh bert oh whenever i see bert
he'll go i went to marie t and i saw
[ __ ] rose
rose is always there in the afternoon
but today she was sitting with these
three [ __ ] knuckleheads
so about a year ago marie etc hired like
a parking lot attendant
who's a [ __ ] really good guy i've had
20 comments at first i thought he was a
[ __ ] myself
but one day he came up to me he goes you
can park that bro don't worry about it i
was like really
it says just 10 minutes he goes just
stay there don't worry i know you're
going to sit and write and stuff
so ever since that i tried to help the
guy out whenever i go down and leave my
dishes on the table i pick them up
and bring them back i don't even know
like the rest of the [ __ ] because all
those people make good money but they
act like white [ __ ] supremacies over
there like they act like [ __ ]
they don't do nothing they look down on
the mexican help over there they're
disgusting [ __ ] people
who got a little bit of success in
hollywood like middle level writers or
something you think they're [ __ ]
ingrid bergman
you know the women that pull in there
they just pull in there they don't park
right
a lot of women in that name they don't
park right well anyway
i'm sitting there i'm sitting there and
the next thing you [ __ ] know
the next thing you [ __ ] know the guy
comes running to the back
and i'm sitting in the corner but i
don't you know i don't know i don't
smoke
so i don't know what's smoking and not
not smoking
okay you don't say anything fair enough
so i hear him say to one of the kids do
me a favor can you put that cigarette
out or go to that side of the coffee
shop and smoke
and the kid goes yeah man and he walks
away
and i don't know i got earphones on no i
don't no i don't
i'm sitting there right and i'm looking
up but i'm paying attention to my own
world you know when you're writing and
you're on your own world right yeah
you're not paying attention but i'm
looking that direction
or something makes me look up okay and i
see the security guard running towards
me oh no all right
can i call you lee and tell you about
this no
and he runs towards me and i think he's
gonna say something to me
i don't know i'm high i don't [ __ ]
know i'm just
stoned in the corner trying to write my
business drink my green [ __ ] tea and
at 10 45 i'll leave go and put my guy on
and shoot the jiu jitsu that's the plan
to make a protein shake
it's about 10 20 at this time
i don't know why these kids aren't in
school and the next thing you [ __ ]
know he goes hey
i just told you to put that cigarette
out the kid kept [ __ ] smoking it and
smiling
so he tells the kid listen
i'm asking you [ __ ] nicely right he
doesn't curse nothing these are nice
white people
he says i'm asking you nicely either get
up i'm gonna have to call the police
and finally as this dude that's always
there
there's this big [ __ ] dude that's
bald like he shaves his head
you could tell at one time or another he
could have been a rough neck he's big
he's big he has that white dog you're
gonna read tea in this coffee white dog
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he owns that
white dog and he says stay with another
old timer
and they just sit there and finally
for some reason this guy gets up and he
goes hey
he's telling you nicely i'm not gonna
tell you that nicely
get the hell up or go put the cigarette
out
now now i gotta turn around
now i gotta turn around because they're
gonna argue behind me oh there's gonna
be a fist fight [ __ ] behind me and
i'm gonna be right there and i don't
mind kicking one of these kids in the
[ __ ] kneecaps because you could tell
that three little [ __ ] right
the kid's smiling and something goes
don't tell you put the cigarette bro
this kid walked up to him finally when
he was three feet from him the kid threw
the cigarette down and stepped on it
he goes you're happy
and the guy goes okay do me a favor get
out of here
and he goes i'm not getting out of here
you're gonna have to throw me out
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
it's gonna go down the guy goes no i'm
gonna [ __ ] call the cops
so my god damn it
i gotta be a [ __ ] witness
they're gonna ask me stupid questions
you know
well how the [ __ ] do i get out of this
and finally the big white dude
starts yelling at the kid
calling him a little [ __ ] you ain't
[ __ ] look at your little [ __ ] friends
you got no class they had like a [ __ ]
audi
829 z convertible with rocket ship rings
you know
and finally goes get the [ __ ] out of
here
the kids head to their car
as they're walking in the kid that was
johnny smooth
looks up and he goes i hope you're not a
[ __ ] actor
my dad's the executive producer
of the hottest show on abc and i'm gonna
make sure he doesn't [ __ ] hire you
bald headed [ __ ]
and he got in his car and took off that
was that was his weapon
that his dad wouldn't give you a [ __ ]
role in a movie or a tv show
that's what i live with people
what's your come to my world i i i ran
over knocked on the glass and asked them
brody i don't give a [ __ ] what show i
don't wanna do business with that little
[ __ ] half a [ __ ]
those guys don't show up at starbucks we
get tweakers at starbucks we don't but
you're on laurel canyon so you get
everybody who [ __ ] falls off the 101.
but it's literally only a five-minute
walk if that and it's two different
worlds two different worlds two
different ones i get the [ __ ] people
who think uh
you know yeah the the screenwriter yeah
the screenwriter
i had my problem i sit there and listen
to those [ __ ] talk oh and i
just giggled that's the show
we plant a tape recorder and we play it
and we listen to all the [ __ ]
stories we used to hear we first moved
here because they were all [ __ ]
stories see i'd rather sit with the
psych the weirdos oh no no me too
they're more interesting too
when i go over there now if i go out
during the week and lee tapes my set lee
emails it to me
and i listen to it there i put earphones
on i plug it in on my phone
and i listen to it there in peace
and i don't have to listen to those
[ __ ] there's a dude who shows up
there
with an earpiece
okay
this shirt is ironed to the tee the
panther designer the shoe's a designer
the belt is designer
the bmw is like a five series and i'm
going to tell you something the guy's up
to his [ __ ] and hawk
yeah okay because i saw i've been there
three times
and i've seen the three clients he's
been with he's horrifically bad
and he's terribly cheesy
he's one of those managers you first
sign here when you get here who meets
with you
and wants to know what you're doing and
what's know about your acting class and
how's it going
and that they just had a meeting with
cbs about you last week and your name
came up for a new pilot
keep going acting class and
it was he's that he's been there three
different times
with three different clients and every
time i sit next to him like i'm writing
and i'm not looking at him i'm just
listening to him
blow smoke up this poor bastard's ass
he was there with a guy a couple weeks
ago
that i look like mr olympia next to this
[ __ ] guy
and he's telling there's a ton of rope
the guy was bending the chair
he held away six he was an extra 600
pound man
that's how big he was standing for the
chat other shots you know and i felt
like looking at him going how many rolls
have you seen ralphie man
they're like listen go [ __ ] go on a
diet this guy's like no
there's a new show on cbs coming out
about fat guys that live together yeah
that's what they want to what are they
gonna do show them breaking the bed
what the [ __ ] they're gonna let them do
that kevin james show no no no no no you
know it's just
it's so uh
like i can't i don't ever want to
redo
or need to explain to people
my first three or four years in this
town and i didn't fall guys i could tell
you guys right out as a man i didn't
fall for any of the [ __ ]
i went to a [ __ ] meeting once
i had a at that at this time i had like
three agents
and one of them was a bottom feeder
i still talked to him he's out of the
management business
but he sent me an audition on a saturday
once he goes joey this movie looks
interesting
just go down there it's an hour on a
saturday and it was right down the block
from me
it was across the street at gardner
gardner stages
downstairs number they used to do a
comedy show there one of your friends
what's his name
adam gropman no uh yeah stan or dan
bailey yeah dan bailey used to do a show
downstairs yeah and gardner yeah yeah
yeah downstairs this is three [ __ ]
years ago four years ago when dan was
doing it yeah i'm talking about 1998 in
that basement in japan i know on
a saturday at 9 00 a.m
in that thing with 40 guys dressed in
mob suits and [ __ ] they were every
different gang affiliation
every different gang affiliation was in
there this guy was making
the biggest gang mafia movie ever in
hollywood you ready guys
we got there on a saturday at nine
o'clock
he promised food a table read and then
auditioning
there was none of the above what he
wanted you there was to tell you that
this is how you got the role in this
movie you got to get investors
oh it's like a bringer movie yeah it was
like a bringing movie he so he would
give you envelopes and he was going to
have a meeting a week later
to see how many investors you got in the
week with promise irene notes this was
crazy
i sat there just giggling this sounds
like a scheme oh my god no [ __ ] lee oh
no no this was way before kickstarter
yeah i was gonna say it sounds just like
yeah no it was like that it was like a
human kickstarter oh it's funny so he's
like whatever comes back next saturday
and at least has 25 000 in promissory
notes what it's a good idea you want me
to tell you something bro
i guarantee three of those people showed
up
i would have just to be in a movie
league you'd be
surprised would they be the people
investing
would they like invest for themselves
they'd like go to family because that's
what this guy's doing he would get if he
asked 40 people in the room
to give him 20 grand and four people
showed up with 20 that's really you
could shoot something
i could shoot something for 80. well at
least if they shoot yeah
yeah i just imagined it was a guy coming
into town good idea getting like 80 000
and like piecing out and going to mexico
listen people shoot movies
for no budget all the time i
personally don't believe in it because
some way the movie's gonna crash and
burn
you have to have money for certain
things there's things that
i i could ask brody stevens to come with
his microphone yeah and with his
cassette deck for three days
probably a big favor we don't have the
money brody how long i know you just
come by for three days yeah let me do
comedy i'll come by you and do a free
show no problem
but i can't go to brody and go brody
yeah i need you for six weeks six weeks
yeah six days a week for free i i can't
yeah yeah and that's what these i'll do
some tweets for you that's what these
people really want to do that much of a
commitment oh [ __ ] that that's insane oh
yeah these people are crazy out here six
weeks so free i was doing
those hundred dollar day movies yeah
i say 50 of the staff is getting paid
the rest of them are there
sold on the experience package
if you do this you get experience
which you know what guys
if i move out here
and i'm here and i got two three
thousand dollars in the bank
and i live with a roommate my rent is
four hundred dollars
and i'm looking to get into the movie
business because that's how it happened
not even getting to the movie yes i'm
looking to get to something and somebody
comes to me and says listen my friend's
doing a movie and he's looking for free
guy you want to come in for six weeks
you know what i got money in the bank
it's nice i get to mingle know people i
don't work on a hollywood movie i would
do it because i had no interest in the
film i don't want to be an actor
so i would go on a set for six and learn
for free
how to carry [ __ ] yeah that's what i did
i did that when i was taking my
my stand-up comedy course i was also
an intern on a usc masters thesis
film so i was a key grip i was learning
about lights i was learning about
shoot where we shot down we shot in uh
south central los angeles in the house
where they peop they came from under the
stairs the people from under the stairs
that movie it was shot in that house and
then we did an overnight shoot on the
radford lot where they had seinfeld
going on and roseanne i remember riding
a bicycle around i went inside the side
and felt sad but anyway i worked on this
film i learned all about like
catering hours teamsters
but i also learned that i wanted to be
the actor the town but i was nowhere
near ready but i learned that i didn't
want to be in movies in fact i did one
other one they wanted me to work for
free we did it at usc
so this is a different film i'm up there
sitting up there with like freaking
sandbags and stuff
and they go so tomorrow six a.m in the
desert and then i go after that i was
just and so they had lunch break and i
just went to burger king and left i
still got invited to the wrap party but
that's when i walked away i said i'm not
gonna i know i'm not gonna do that
direction i want to do stand-up and like
even when i moved up to seattle i worked
at the comedy underground i learned
about seeding the show i learned about
you know a host a guest spot a middler
uh a headliner but i wasn't like a huge
comedy fan actually i still you know i
like laughing at my friends i like
it's different like when somebody's
presenting things and
i'm aw you know i'm weird maybe i'm just
immature about that my brother i'm 47 i
just turned 47
may 20. i met you when you were
25.
yeah i was born in seventies so no i was
probably yeah twenty-five twenty-five
yeah you think you're dealing with joy
bananas yeah i gotta know man 25.
i'm glad i went to seattle i really
because i grew up here in the valley i
grew up i went to college in arizona and
it was like just too much sunshine too
much
you know doing
people don't develop stand up in arizona
i was plus i was a baseball player you
know that baseball but i had i wanted to
go up to seattle and be around pierced
ears and
music and all that weird stuff i knew i
had to get out of la and uh you know i
took that comedy course at ucla
graduated at the comedy store and i did
that one open mic in chatsworth and i go
that ain't for me i grew up here in the
valley i can't have some host i get it i
understand it because i played baseball
i learned all about
group think and all that playing
baseball it all comes into like
you know in life
playing sports being you know at a high
level you journal you do learn dirt you
do learn about discipline when i played
baseball baseball at arizona state we
represented the school you couldn't get
in trouble it'd be in the newspaper we
got drug tested
but i learned about
just taught me discipline and but
learning and getting picked on you know
oh brody the jewish guy gay guy run
weird this [ __ ] punching me but i
knew that's how it was i mean i was
liked in high school i was a good
pitcher all of a sudden so they tried
and i s they tr i go i'm not gonna quit
you know they didn't get me out of there
but i'm not a quitter and i just stuck
it out i can go a long story about that
but these guys were hard on me and i
didn't complain
they would go uh yeah you're a jewish
guy how did the grand canyon get started
two uh you know
jews fighting over a nickel and a
squirrel hole oh thanks for laughing but
you're jewish too but
but i didn't care that's kind of what it
was because i played baseball also in
high school you know and i was around
football so
i it just made me it made me tougher it
made me strong and i just rose above it
they would say oh brody you're jew or
something i go well jesus was jewish and
they get pissed like these christian
guys but
you know
they're good friends like it was kind of
amazing thing you know because i got
picked on at raceto high school growing
up and it's different getting picked on
by inner city kids you got it malicious
you know i had cr i'd rather get hazed
by a christian
that's okay that's that's a that's a
that's i don't need to be gang jumped
into something
i'm so upset with politics it stressed
me out big time when i first met you i
used to break your balls constantly yes
you used to make me laugh
and i used to break your balls because
we had a friend
and he did porn and i asked you if you
did poor like you used to do
you went extra on a porn movie that
would josh wolf under the bus
and then you had that cable access show
and i would torment your life
about the cable access show till you put
me on i think he was you i think you
want it oh my god i'm looking at you and
all these memories are coming back
seattle was a great scene it was really
uh
i don't know how it is now but we were
just still very great still great still
great for comedy
a lot of young comics up there is what i
hear
you know i run reed moved to arizona oh
he did yeah so i don't know who's
phoenix or something oh wow so i don't
know who's gonna run the contest and all
that so listen brody
when i was a kid i loved basketball
yeah i loved [ __ ] basketball lee look
it up
what year the seattle supersonics go to
the nba finals
when in the 90s are you talking about
the one against the goals the 70s yeah
79 i think 78 79 they beat the
washington bullets one of those years
one of those years 77
77 i think was portland and i know
uh yeah something that was julius
serving they won in 79 79 yeah there you
go well you're a bad [ __ ]
something like well my cousins lived
there i saw i saw that team i didn't
know anything about seattle and one day
the basketball team is great
and they started showing pictures of the
of the city when they were up there yeah
to show the stadium before they played
i'm like what an interesting
[ __ ]
city
okay
and then that was it i just made a
mental note
and then in 87
or 88 or 89 i'm in a movie theater
watching goodfellas
and they're talking about how he ended
up in seattle washington
this is way before the internet how does
a gang mafia dude from the city where he
was a [ __ ] he ended up being a [ __ ]
but how does a guy from brooklyn
end up in seattle
so i always talk about [ __ ] seattle
seattle and anytime something good
happened then they had the football team
who i loved jim zorn
one night i bet
san diego
against seattle or something on monday
night football i don't know what year it
was lee let me tell you something jim
zorn put such a beat on me
in three or four minutes
that i ended up liking them after that
so i was always intrigued by sandy ah by
seattle
and then when i first started doing
comedy just like you i started two years
before you there was a publication that
came out of
san francisco called
was it a comedy magazine yes
that john fox and his company put out
and they interviewed comics
they told you different they previewed
clubs
if a new club was open they'd do a
write-up about the club right it was a
really good magazine it really was
and the most interesting thing about it
was the last three pages was
all the open mics in the country
like that were big time open mics then
the last two pages were all the comedy
clubs
with the insignia of the club
and seattle's was the coolest
the insignia they gave you
with the [ __ ] black and the white the
black and the white no no no what was
that
that picture of the
see if you come up with seattle comedy
competition look at this the globe the
globe with the dude holding it yeah or
something like this watch how cool this
is lee
this stuck out in that [ __ ] newspaper
like
and i always should i search in like the
90s or
no seattle comedy competition
that's it preston's seattle comedy
competition or the comedy underground
there's just something about the
northwest the fresh air i knew nothing
about that [ __ ] until you got it i
didn't know nothing about salmon
i knew nothing about [ __ ] nothing i
knew henry hill went there i knew that
the supersonics were there yeah and then
something really [ __ ] happened
i discovered a band called soundgarden
and i was like oh see right there all
the way you see that
yeah even that was
up in this newspaper
uh
that that thing right there yeah was
something that they had
in the newspaper in this publication and
i was like that one and i circled that
club
and every time i would go to a comedy
club and they had the new issue of that
magazine
i would look to see what comedy clubs
were opening what was closing and i'd
always circle that [ __ ] club
and for some reason i wanted to go to
[ __ ] seattle
then soundgarden comes out
i'm hearing about this heroin
i'm hearing about all this [ __ ] up there
not one thing that i hear about comedy i
didn't really ask
i didn't think in my mind i was in the
level to go to seattle like i was just
getting to getting it together in
boulder you know in denver area
and then i went to [ __ ] michigan to
do my first feature act
and i met a [ __ ] stripper oh and she
said she was going to seattle
and then she said i'll swing by boulder
and get you
and that was the plan and
i didn't hear from her for a week
and one day i got a call she's in
boulder
she came to get here so i gave him my
stuff and i was up there 10 days later
and then we went there that was a crazy
romantic comedy just like it's just you
[ __ ] believe that i met a memorial
day weekend
and i was in bowl and i was in seattle
five weeks later remember how i tell you
that people always say well i'm gonna go
to seattle and do comedy that's my dream
so what are you doing now well right now
i'm working at starbucks putting away
money i'm putting away money listen
you're never going to put that money
away
that's a [ __ ] that's a resistance
read the book the art of war that's a
resistance
what you need to do is
go get the most expensive job you can
get right now i don't give a [ __ ] what
it is if it's taking [ __ ] out of a box
and they give you 14 hours when they got
overtime
you're gonna do that for 30 days okay at
the end of the 30 even if you put 100 a
week
away at the end of the four weeks you
got 400 you got your car
you got your health
and i'm sure your grandmother will throw
you an extra 250 and that's 6.50 you
could start a new [ __ ] life with 6.50
how do i know because i've started a new
life with doing hours so you're not
going to tell me no [ __ ]
stories you know what i'm saying yeah
are you saying 6 50 today
what where's that back then i'm talking
about
this is what's the where you want to go
you go brodie that's what i did yeah i
went to seattle these people looking in
your face and going
my dream is to move to new york and just
listen that was one of my dreams the
more you [ __ ] with the you got to
put away money the more you're going to
die because if you really have a dream
you'll live in a shelter and you'll get
a job tap dancing oh i don't know
you're a [ __ ] listen
dog i lived in a car i sacrificed l.a in
the car do you think when i got into
comedy i told you i was gonna live in a
car
maybe but then i heard stan hope was
doing it this guy was doing it this guy
was doing it one night i fell asleep in
the car and i woke up i didn't need any
chiropractors oh like it helped your
back no i go this ain't that bad i
realized i could take showers at the
comedy store and i could pay child
support plus not cocaine plus eat and
survive in l.a
yeah by saving that little money every
month
then gavin would help me out by sleeping
on this couch
from time to time you know it was a
struggle
and then i kind of moved in with gavin
then i moved in with my wife and the
rest is [ __ ] history here
but you know
i have you told me
joey when you get into calm you're going
to be homeless at one point you're like
well describe homeless homeless is
disgrace homeless is the scariest
[ __ ] word
in the world because the first thing you
think of is that dude by 7-eleven wrote
a blanket on himself this morning next
to the [ __ ] tanks where they fill him
for barbecue i swear to god the on
magnolia this morning by the park right
there was just a dude laying there like
a mummy coming from head to toe next to
the tanks
20 years ago i would have shot a bb into
those tanks
blown him the [ __ ] chick he had with
him the dog i mean when you think of
homeless
that's what you think of okay no
let me tell you what homeless is
having money having a job
and for some reason or another you lost
your apartment
and god you know what
thank god you have a car
because you're never homeless
there were times i was homeless with a
car
and there was times i was homeless
without a car
and guess what
both times i survived
my seat doesn't go back anyway the the
button
to lie down no i can sleep in my car i
have to go in the back seat and curl up
sure the one i really want to talk to
are the rv people that i've never seen
and i'm that sounds terrible but the rfv
people i i didn't see that on the east
coast like i never really saw people
living in rvs
but here it's everywhere
well
if you think about it
you want to talk about mistakes is it
comedian
yeah what a [ __ ] mistake
buying a
trailer like that after you're doing
comedy three or four years yeah you have
to decide what you want to do
in this economy you're not just going to
send resumes in the tape
because the best thing you can do is
that 400 dollars you save
your [ __ ] fill up the tanks
you get peanut butter jelly ramen
you put water in that shower and you
live in an rv and you go cross-country
going to comedy club [ __ ] yeah because
then that's exciting you wouldn't have
to worry about the condos once
you just go to every night you perform
somewhere else and if there's no show
there's a show now because you're there
with a microphone and two speakers
but that's how you do comedy in the
beginning
that's how people i like that idea no
not now today is that still plausible oh
my god bro you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want you're single i need to do it
you're free
you know you could get somebody to
sponsor you brody called the brody
stevens rv show i want to go to i want
to do
for
i don't know how at this point you don't
need help what you could do is there's a
thing that is your best friend what
internet
unbelievably
unbelievably what you could do on the
internet
on on a nickel's worth
i still help and it would take you
i could get an executive producer by
tomorrow
i love baseball i have access i could
talk to him tomorrow morning and he'd do
the whole thing with he could double
executive producer
road manager
driver and keep your head together yeah
that means it's going to cost you a big
percentage nobody works
yeah well what about i'll give him what
about i have to have merch too
he'll help me with that he'll help you
with the merch and he won't take a piece
here much here's you know i did a
festival um
a couple few weeks ago and one of the
rock bands they liked uh they liked what
i was doing and they they thought it'd
be a good idea maybe opening they wanted
a comedian to open up with them on the
road and they were pretty cool guys like
pretty straight lace guys i rocked out
they're called uh
diarrhea planet they're out of nashville
but they they rock you have no idea that
you know like i told you before the
podcast started you still have that same
insecurity i have yeah
you're not good feel better now at this
point it's over
at this point if they didn't get it by
now
you know brought you and i'm gonna get
it
but can i say one thing yeah and say
what the [ __ ] you want
i have um
yeah people i get it people get it
but
i haven't because i did so much audience
warm-up
behind the scenes you know and i got
great at that but it also
stifled i feel like my stand-up career
because i was getting yes i was getting
that paycheck i was getting that mic
time i was meeting everybody i was
getting opportunities but i also knew
that i had this
consistent warm-up gig usually at best
damn sports show where you were and i
also had
a connection with baseball i always
wanted to be around baseball all right
so here's a [ __ ] deal right now it's
june nobody gives a [ __ ] about baseball
yet right because uh houston's running
away with it you know it's a [ __ ]
nightmare so
right now what you could do is the next
three weeks is make a few you got you
sit down
you honestly look at yourself you sit
down and you get a piece of paper and a
pencil
all right piece of paper pencil
see i should be doing a a weekly podcast
and you're going to actually
tickets to baseball games okay okay i
need a
field press package field pass all right
which is all easy but can i say one
thing yeah
mlb is weird you know you can't
necessarily use
show logos or anything understand you're
not gonna show a [ __ ] logo this is
welcome to brody stephen's world like
yes i'm here at dodger stadium you got
it it's just even me just talking to the
camera at the stadium
i'm walking into the parking lot what's
going on this is periscope september
yeah after a [ __ ] month of the
playoff coverage
and once again by the world series
fox will be hunting you down around the
corner i tried to have them do that
about right now you got the world by the
balls you have the experience i don't
know
yes i do all you need is you have this
what you need is a sponsorship from an
rv company oh sponsorship we need an rv
company to sponsor you this yeah you're
gonna have to spring for the driver so
we're gonna combine this into a comedy
tour
life of brody life of brody okay don't
even mention baseball because it
involves everything it still involves
pulling over on the side of the road
doing kettlebells absolutely smoking
reefer going to subway and taping black
people shuffling
my instagram like my instagram video
this is this is this is full fledged
it's just having fun the the most
important is this guy that's driving and
whatever you got to rock his world who's
he
where do i find him are there guys who
do that okay i gotta make one call and
you're hooked up okay all right number
two you're gonna you know the rv two
people sleep but every three or four
nights you got to stop the whole time
wash your ass right and get away from
him wi-fi you could also get a hotel
sponsor wi-fi can i i i'm in this could
you i really get sponsorship for stuff
because i'm open to it i need help
well i mean would you you could do all
this you think you think he should only
have the rv sponsor
no he could have the rv sponsor vitamins
i like that i mean
yes he could have uh hotel maybe i mean
what kind of hotel are you looking for
how fast remember this is all corporate
so if you're looking to do it this on
september this is and everybody goes on
vacation in july drum drum lessons in
different cities but i could see
a national rv company
every city you stop in
do a periscope live with an amount of
numbers print up the amount of numbers
print up the times that you do the
periscope
and let's do a sample let's go from a
dodger game to an anaheim game two games
in one day right
and let's uh show it that way let me
give some shout outs hold on one second
i don't know i don't know organization
is the key and this is not a lot of
things to organize this is not a lot of
moving parts here
brandon gonzalez you know i love you
fudge packing
101 matt i love it
alan stevens stay with me baby jack w
lewis may 23
mike pinock
caleb bass and o.g
dunkhead damon are you kidding me or
what
do not forget about the brayer improv
tomorrow night do not forget about the
[ __ ] working out with uncle joey on
the 15 at the ice house and do not
forget about governors
the 24th and 25th we ain't [ __ ]
around two shows
chinese food the whole [ __ ] thing
people stabbing anyway but don't worry
about that [ __ ] all you need to worry
about is bread tomorrow night that's all
you need to worry about if you got any
if you're not doing dick tomorrow night
lee syed doesn't even know what's going
to hit him tomorrow
he's tomorrow tomorrow night we're going
for broke all right anyway we're talking
tonight no no tonight's just a warming
up for tomorrow night and then
here's the deal brother this is a very
easy thing
you have to contact periscope you have
to contact
uh you know i can hook you up with a few
people that maybe throw you some ads on
the periscope the comedy club is because
comedy comes don't give a [ __ ]
i i need here i honestly
i need structure that's what
people tell me where to go what to do be
brody
do this do that comedy clubs on the way
like a one night or do you want to go do
a rock club okay who looks right now
like they're going
to the world series of the playoffs
if you had a the season ended today
astros
nationals
dodgers
probably not maybe not dodgers just
throwing them out there
you don't want the dodgers because then
you have to do a comedy show here you do
comedy every [ __ ] night we need to
get you to play off cities
and then what do i do in these cities
what are you doing in this city yeah
let's say let's say there's you get up
nice and early and you go to the hot
spot where people eat breakfast
with my camera dude you take a camera
dude with you
you sit down you eat you explain the
food you pray
right then you'd go exercise okay and
then you go to on periscope on periscope
and you go visit the baseball players
that you were friends with
and go see what they're doing and
interview them maybe
and you're walking on thin tunnels but
this is advertising baby it's brody
stevens i've been coming to you for
years now i gotta walk in like a pirate
no i'm down by the field i gotta i have
a pass i'm legitimate okay
so these guys are gonna act different in
front of me as opposed to
uh somebody they don't know they're
going to be more open with me you're
going to see that scene in [ __ ]
apocalypse now
when they land and
uh
it's actually oliver stone directing
and that you know and i know he directs
the movie now there's a scene when the
uh
the people land uh
you know
the martin sheen lands with the other
[ __ ] guy
tom hayden and the godfather duval when
they land
and as they're splitting up into the
kill the vietnamese people
the [ __ ] there's a director there
going keep moving keep moving don't look
at the camera don't look at the camera
that'd be the funny thing every time you
shake somebody's hand just be go be
natural don't look at the camera and
just talk to them so you have a hook
always to go in there you talk to them
ask them how they're feeling blah blah
blah
go to the other side pick your favorite
player on the other side
go talk to him if it's an afternoon game
take the comedy show at 10 o'clock at
the comedy club right
take a percentage of the door and go in
there so now after the baseball game but
that's tricky because after a baseball
game nobody's gonna go to a comedy club
but you're absolutely gonna have
different people who watch your own
periscope because they're fans of what
you do so they're gonna actually pay
to go watch you so you can finance these
little trips
that way also
i don't know if you're going to be
listening you're my brother i wish you
only the best i want you to sell out
these notatoriums well i don't know but
listen 100 tickets
yeah well i'm fine with rock clips 20
[ __ ] bucks you could spend more than
one day in each city so what if you went
to the game and was being brody and
advertised this show at the club the
next night
it would be sold out yeah you'd do great
brody there's an angle here bro i just
need that you know what i just need to
take you
okay i came to terms spreading the joy
ten years ago that i'm not the
conventional comment johnny carson ain't
calling jay leno ain't calling ain't
nobody [ __ ] called uncle joey
everything i've had i had a [ __ ] herd
and wherever they end up i end up and
i'm very happy because i'm here i'm
still here
we go all the way back to seattle
yeah
1995. how many people from that era do
you see at the comedy store sunday night
when i was sitting next to you be honest
with you tell the people at home how
many [ __ ] people
know that we were up there with are
still down here oh josh josh wolf
craig ass is around crack gasses around
um from that era
not nobody really no
so how fortunate are we
i ended up in seattle by mistake dog
but yesterday when i was talking to john
she says he still remembers
sitting with you at the volcano
with the volcano with tana
right mark garner okay you all had your
notebooks out he goes it was so life was
so different that
i have an interesting story about the
volcano are you is that the cafe yes
oh
cafe not the bulldog oh he goes some
days you really miss that you really
miss
that part of comedy how you're really
hungry
and i go you know if anybody's still
really hungry it's brody that's what we
were talking about yesterday
he goes i guess you're right i go no no
no no i can't i don't have
the
cardio
to what we had in seattle
i was sleeping five hours a night in
seattle right and it was either doom and
blow or because i was in love with
comedy yeah and i wanted to get better
at it
and if anybody anybody who has ever done
anything and they want to get better at
it from either from being an electrician
to being a painter you guys know what
i'm talking about when it keeps you up
at night
when comedy keeps you up at night
thinking of your plan
that means you [ __ ] love it
only women keep guys up at night or
bills
or somebody being
sick in your family
but to stay up at night thinking about
the love you have for comedy and how
good you want to be on it while you're
sleeping in an office
above josh wolf's mexican restaurant
where you're paying 125 dollars a month
and you got a little mattress with a
pillow and a blanket
and i thought i was the king of the
[ __ ] world that
i was what what was i
a a 100 yards from the comedy
underground
at that time i thought the underground
that particular one i don't know what
the new one is like yeah but that
particular one
to me i still rank it
the top five stage i've ever stepped on
i hold that stage
so much
low ceilings
that one was theirs the cockroaches the
water bugs on the the bathroom
the best you had to like pull a chain to
flush it
like was there like a chain you would
pull to go to gotta walk up the stairs
and walk down the stairs but when you
walked up the stairs you
opened up the door and there was a
jukebox
and there were always people at the bar
small guy
who was working and poor [ __ ] swanny
jesus
you still see him when you go up there
i think it's closed down isn't it i have
no idea i think swanees is gone well
swanees is gone but then he reopened the
ball with a bunch of people with josh
wolfe's old mexican ball okay so he
hired joshua over there right gotcha
recently
yeah josh was in seattle running to help
him out no
this is 1990 [ __ ] so
i'm sorry no i know about that i
remember that
seven he hired him i went in for the
meeting i worked at red robin i had
experience what red robin did you work
at the one on east lake the original red
robin come on yeah gavin boyd got me the
interview gavin was uh like an assistant
chef at the red robin in uh
over in kirkland hold on timeout
let's get it together there's no
assistant
sushi [ __ ] there's no sushi yes there
was i read robin you're [ __ ] and all
the materials come already
what sous chef there's no soup chef they
had him at red robin listen you got a
red ramen there's three mexicans and
they all call themselves one just in
case well we have food runners
yeah yeah food runners too but i worked
at the original
sous chef i remember asking
listen ask evan listen don't get me
wrong i love red rabbit yeah those
cheeseburgers the red ramen the fries
the fruits the refills i might you know
what i may go
where is it it's up into hungary canyon
no to paying there
no no no no
yeah yeah yeah me and my wife went up
there with the baby
and red robin and we were like what when
i called lee i called
my red robin having a cheeseburger with
steak fries [ __ ] steak fries what to
paying them all that's where i was in
that red robin when uh i found out that
kobe
got caught for rape
that was two weeks ago that was two
weeks ago no son there's a joke there
but i really was when jim hill announced
it that was you you know where i'm
working more when i found out magic had
aids
yeah where was i for that that was i was
just
and i was getting water lemonade
lee you would have drank 18 of these at
four o'clock why would i drink rose
water late you never drink anything i've
had it with water i like lemonade but no
no no this is
lemonade made with rose water this is 20
like no perot magic uh that that was so
surreal that was surreal the oj just the
magic you just couldn't believe
that oj it was basketball season it was
the playoffs and i was at my main man
danny feebles
at one of her softball games and we were
waiting for the pigeon to land if you
know what i'm talking about and the
pigeon was landing big
in those days i had held out like five
days pigeon i was washing cars at
national rental car in boulder
i was delivering sandwich with the deli
zone dudes
i was putting it togetherly i was
delivering chinese food i was slinging a
little bit but we had a different
connection and he sold you were slinging
some pigeon i was doing everything
getting chicks i wasn't getting no
chicks oh you had a girlfriend no i had
nothing in bold at this time i was just
a single dude from time to time i bump
into a victim i'd go celebrate for like
a [ __ ]
eight months and then i'd bump into a
chick that would take me to the cleaners
i wouldn't know what happened yeah and
that was no good they gave me one time
they know i'm no good
i'm all coated out and do a couple dirty
things but besides that i'm no good free
porn has really changed the game
i think i don't like porn
it's quick and easy
have you have you looked at what i like
brodie like the live cameras oh you're
no i haven't i like that it's just
people there's it's you can watch people
and it's right there it's happening live
could you send me the link please yeah
it's chatterbait.com
chatterbait and you can watch people
have sex live yeah it's crazy couples
girls is it free yeah
okay uh i'll see you guys later
see you later no i'm slurring my words
because i take the clown up and
leave disgusting i can't believe you sit
there and watch those naked people
why don't your parents do a nice job but
you're naked live people do you even
donate a dollar [ __ ] no what type season
i'm saying why would i donate a dollar
because you're watching them they have
people doing that they have people they
get them they get advertising right no
no they don't get advertising but they
get people to send them amazon gift
cards and that's what i get some chicks
showing you a put they put the [ __ ]
right by the camera yeah they'll do
whatever you want you ask them to if
i've never asked for anything if i was
going to ask for something they ask you
the tip though they have scratched the
snip
that's coming in 2018. that's how
that's on apple 2018
they accept paypal of course right
like the version of this computer joey
if we had to rebuy this it's five
thousand dollars and this one was like
1900.
when we bought it four years ago but
it's a desktop right oh you just put the
kiss of death on it this is going to go
down down a weak [ __ ] oh no it's
[ __ ] crazy no that's how apple hasn't
programmed dog
but like whiteboard hasn't progressed
are you ready to press the button yep
also
two million computers go out we're all
running to the store five million a
piece five g's a piece they go on
[ __ ] uh forbes they made 82 million
and 15 minutes sure because i zapped
everybody's computer real quick my
battery's slow
with a slow battery it's crazy lee what
a [ __ ] rocket they've created apple
yeah they're amazing they're like
communism they got you hooked everything
is though yeah they really got you
hooked to corporations i've seen the
growth
globalism capitalism i've lived
through the
the growth
yes we have and it's been amazing
the different
i don't know
i don't know how to word this without
something just
just the growth of everything
i love gps that's positive
hey there
once you make a decision with computers
or phones it's kind of hard to get off
of it
because you learn something all your
things on are in certain uh ways so i i
would love to switch to an android but
i don't really have the time to learn a
new file i just i'm going to get the new
iphone even though this phone was shitty
from the very beginning i got one of
those duds but they wouldn't do anything
about it
they're happy to share that with me but
if you don't get the new iphone it's the
old one will stay it'll slow down
eventually yeah yeah the other one's got
a button in it too that's what those
they see the expert one night you're on
the phone with your cousin and the phone
zaps and you try to turn it on it turns
back on and often there's no numbers
and also you're going to know an apple
and they read you the bad news
listen your phone
either this you can wait two weeks
and there's a prison in [ __ ] ohio
where they re-fix the phones and send
them back to you but before they send
them to you they suck all the
information there and if you have dirty
pictures they pass them around the index
for ten dollars a picture they whack off
on pictures of your grandmother holding
the cat and [ __ ]
joey that's not far from the truth
that's the truth i wouldn't lie to you
guys it's all it's awesome they send it
back well these things fix those phones
for three [ __ ] 50 an hour
and they sit there
welding back it's prison inmate
somewhere but but you know what they're
doing
for example because i just got a ticket
i was in arizona and i got one of those
photo tickets sent to me and i was going
45 and a 36. no 40s no 4 40
35 i was going 46 i was going 46 and a
35
in arizona and they got me on like some
photo thing
so i guess what's that 11 miles over
no is that so legal the camera it's not
in california but i was in arizona well
the red light ones aren't i'm pretty
sure
this was a speeding one the red lights
are legal i believe they're not i can
check it well they got me and then so i
paid it and then hurts because
they they get it sent then you have to
pay a processing fee
and then you know what eventually it's
going to be like oh he got a ticket now
automatically his insurance goes up
automatically he gets points on his
record it's all i don't want to sound
like uh conspiracy guy but you're
starting to see stuff like that
everything's automated everything's this
and i'm gonna get a ticket for today
you're gonna get a ticket why you're
parked right there no i'm gonna get a
ticket for today guys why i had a
conference call
and everywhere i [ __ ] turned there
was [ __ ] traffic
i pull up to the left
and a lady in front of me the light
turns green and she's in another [ __ ]
planet i knew i was dead i'm stuck
behind it for like two miles at 22 miles
an hour i couldn't go around like it's
unchristian like
i took the [ __ ] beat oh
and i'm like four minutes from the
office and i pull up over over here by
the fire department and they're doing
construction there
they got me waiting out there some
little chubby fire i mean with [ __ ]
stop signs and [ __ ] pass and go
he would let one car every eight minutes
i'm dead
so i made the right right there cut
cut across i was the first guy on the
green light there but there's a bus
station there and when i made the ride i
heard
they took a bunch of pictures i was on
you could hear it yeah
i heard it i was on camera camera
journey no oh well maybe that yeah did
you was it a red light yeah i don't know
here but you said the flash this is in
the la weekly so uh it says i'm telling
you i'm going to get this goldsmith has
ruled against questions about whether or
not you have to pay red light ticket
pretty much you still don't but you know
jesus christ
i was arizona got me
so paid it and what can you do and it
probably
takes points on my record and maybe i
should have done traffic school but f it
hopefully i'll book a gig and cover it
all because i haven't booked that gig
yet you know i should have a special
which i shot and it's not
out yet necessarily i should have an
album i did so much warm up but joey
everything you've said is right you told
me to go to new york you're
giving me structure here you're giving
me i mean like i said i need male energy
i was raised by you know my parents were
divorced my mom my sister that's why i i
don't get political but i said that
hillary stuff doesn't work it's going to
stress you out i grew up in it i was
bust i did the private school and i knew
right away those private school kids
were weird they were weird they were
kind of elitist i saw it i was
uncomfortable i'm a good guy so i would
get picked on by the elitist types and
also i would get picked on by
like blue collar guys i get picked on by
elitist and i get picked on by african
americans that's what i got picked on
and you saw like the different energies
between
you know but that's kind of stuff made
me a comedian getting picked on i say
thank god i did that because
i i right now
i use it as fuel i and i'm saying like
you know i'm a little high you know
that's what happens but the point is
i'm i'm thankful that's why sports
getting hazed being a rookie you know
having to do those kind of uh you know
treated that way helps you makes you a
stronger stand-up having these problems
you know
today
i guess
you know you could be a good looking guy
have a perfect life and be funny and you
know that's a way to go too i guess but
is that right i mean isn't it funny kind
of still when the guy's in pain and
suffering but it seems like these days
you don't have to
it'd be great to me
sorry about that those stars are getting
to me the stars again to you but
i'm just kind of i'm stressed out
because you everything you talk about
you talk about bills you know joey you
are best damn sports show i've seen it
you've been in the movies i feel
i was in the movies too it's like extra
pressure i was telling my mom today it
was like you know i'm willing to live in
my car too not necessarily for comedy
but for my mom i got to take care of her
i can't do it but i can sleep on her
couch for 14 days and then i could like
live in the van
14 couch on the 14 days on the couch you
know i'm not a mama's boy but my
sister's not doing it she's working i i
got comedy why do you have to go to the
couch why did you go to the van
well like one day or i guess i could run
do an airbnb casino's arm pumps right
went to one last night out
how many are there probably like five
what area why don't we put the small
room together yeah give uh when you're
down there with your mom have a gig take
care of the daytime at night make sure
she's in bed water
the 911 button
yeah and you shoot it over you do your
hour and a half brodie stevens presents
and even if you start with three people
it's a different market bro to your mind
god just you know i don't
i do not belie with comedy you can waste
so much time brody on periscope right i
don't know tweeting
instagram i'm wasting time
if you think i'm happy with the results
of my life you're crazy
but it's interesting to me
that i'm still here
amongst you guys
that's very interesting to me
interesting so i say to myself every day
wow young other guy was in the hallway
at the comedy store waiting to go up
and there's a lot of pictures in there
that you don't really i don't go in
there i don't go in the booth where
people pay to go in i never go in that
room
i saw comics that were [ __ ] there
kicking ass on it and they're not even
in away anymore
i thought these guys would be here
forever they're gone where do they go
back off into a regular life somewhere i
don't know what happens
because i got into this to do this to
the [ __ ] end
but before i go up i'm like i can't
believe
i'm still doing spots here twenty
[ __ ] years later
so i i know how lucky
we are but at the same time
i'm not as
insecure about my skills
as i used to be
like for years when i got here
i was always very insecure so that's why
when i went on stage
at the comedy store especially if i got
15 minutes i gave you 15 minutes of
thunder
you know what i'm saying what was it
like back then
when we got here in 97 yeah well you
were there for three years yeah i was
the 12 45 guy right yeah i was the 1am
guy 115
12 45 right 30 was the earliest i went
up
yeah
everyone so i'd be walking through the
hallway and they go joey you want to go
up now and do your spot [ __ ] yeah 10 30.
i'm out of there i can stop blowing [ __ ]
so how what was the vibe like in 97 98
99
you hate it
really it was more negative back then
right no no no no it was a different
comic from eight
in those days it was always argus
and then it was just comics a lot of
comics i don't even remember i didn't
know you don't game anymore
so they were there before 11 o'clock
comics right they had credits and [ __ ]
like that then in those days paul mooney
would come in or
and then after that there was an iran
comics i was part of the red comics
after paul mooney
and i would always follow up only
so i would have to go up there while
people were getting up and walking out
so i had two minutes of just refocusing
them right which taught me a lesson
there that's a skill and then how to
it's 12 45 they listen to everything
already by now
just go just start talking and keep
machine gun them and you remember little
bits that you were going to drop on them
yep and it's 12 45. you a joke you wrote
that you think is brilliant is gonna die
a slow debt
and then you have to dig yourself out of
a hole
that [ __ ] 10 vietnamese can't dig
themselves out of you understand me
just [ __ ] cut the joke in half
go for it go for the [ __ ] punch line
and run from there get them first
laughing hard and hope that the rest guy
and if you get them hard at 12 45
it's like when you're in high school and
you play football
first play everybody knows first play
wherever the [ __ ] you're standing across
from
you don't look him in the eye you're
gonna let them know listen this is the
first play
this is your shot to let me know who you
are
oh i gotta let you know who the [ __ ] i
am
whenever i went on stage that's always
the mentality
that's why people used to say i hate
comedy how to expect you to perform in
three minutes i used to be the king of
three minutes
just gotta push just right out of the
gate right out of the gate
why [ __ ] around
whatever the [ __ ] comic in front of
you is voice wise
you're gonna be a little bit louder but
not too loud
and you're going to learn how to pitch
your voice outward
instead of this way
that's what's going to make that room
act differently
you move your voice even though you're
using a microphone jesus christ after 20
years i thought about this and i watched
me a couple weeks ago
i saw myself do it
how
especially in the main room
listen somebody in front of you like
crystallia goes up in front of you in
the main room
and you have to follow that that's death
that's hard that's death g
so you got
39 seconds
after crystalline
or you're gonna have a long night how do
i know i lived that horror show
about twice already
i did good behind them the night in the
main room and the original
yeah i brought you up there yeah
that was fun
because there's two different energies
in those rooms yeah main room compared
to the or i could be dying in the
original room and kick it up after the
eight minute mark
because i know it's the energy yeah and
once i feel energy i got to pray for
that second
right to land yeah that that second
right land we're taking a ride for the
last seven minutes yes i will get off on
the big applause as soon as i see that
big light
and i walk out of there smelling like a
rose yep it's just like going into a 15
round fight
losing the first eight rounds
and winning the last [ __ ] seven not
to mention you knock them out with 10
seconds left yes that's
the journey yes that's the journey and a
lot of people don't want to take that
journey
because those eight minutes of hell me
i've lived in hell [ __ ]
i don't do nothing uncle joey i've been
up there for 20 minutes and nobody's
left
eight minutes is an eternity
but i know at some point i have jokes
that i can turn this room around or
i can just lose my [ __ ] mind
and then rely on the jokes later if i
lose my mind and i get them oh my name
is the italians say
because then i got the prepared material
coming behind that
it's like steel only
it's just like steel you just got to do
the work you're not going to learn these
things out about yourself
unless you don't do the work and most
importantly you write them down
tape them write them down
write them down i would do the youth
hostel every wednesday night every
sunday night the audience warm-up was
the other thing that just start stop
getting these high school kids in
getting these paid audience and
community college i mean i cut my teeth
doing that i because
i was
had to get over to learn to public speak
and i sold t-shirts at the seattle
supersonic games being the waiter
because i was good at baseball but i
wasn't in that artistic world
and then i just had to force myself jay
leno i listened to his book he said you
want to get into comedy learn to public
speak just talk
then i did that cable access show
i did the public speaking
and then i went to new york i was a tour
guide at radio city music hall i barked
at the comedy cellar i did all these
weird things but you know what
i got i got to believe in myself as a
stand-up comedian and
because i've done so many i've spread
thin doing that
i think the last couple years i really
focused on my stand-up and uh
you know put my energy into that and you
know last night or the other night
following you was a great we had a great
time and i really appreciate that and uh
i like these you know
i'm having a great time tonight and it's
about
it's a it's a weird it's a weird world
out there it's a weird world these days
and you got to stay positive i put out
positive energy
and
i don't know what my next guess gig i'm
doing bumper shoot that's what i'm
excited about seattle i'm doing bumper
shoot isn't that ironic isn't that
ironic one of my could be my final
festival who knows it's bumper chute and
that is it's still pat wilson
who knows i don't know that's funny i
don't know who's booking it up there
but there's liable to be a riot you know
that's labor day weekend that's you know
it's it's summertime's over it's seattle
you got people coming up from portland
it's labor day you got lord playing you
got weezer playing you got brody doing
comedy
something's going down in seattle bumper
shoot you heard it here first somebody's
gonna like notify the fbi brody i was
getting information that's my vibe
they're gonna push the [ __ ] tent out
there like they did
remember years ago pat wilson would book
one of the festivals there it was the
local guys kermit appio
the other guy who won rodney sherwood
listen to that
name from the past he was great but
these these like a pat wilson never gave
you know no they didn't give us never
gave it up she gave me the army base
i never even got that then there was a
spanish guy in seattle alberto
who used to book the old improv
which they changed over in fact that's i
saw sound garden at this show box the
show box yes good for you my brother
i think it's still there what was the
name of the bar
that we were going to
across the street from the show box
downstairs
it was very bush rod long used to go
there
he took me i took josh wolfe
then we all started going over there
with comics do you remember that one no
downstairs
seattle had a great energy pioneer
square the music scene was on fire i
mean it was post grunge but then we used
to walk down to mccormick and schmitz
yeah and they were they had the
four to seven o'clock menu
the mooch menu and they had a
cheeseburger okay
clam chowder sourdough bread
oh my god lee and then i went again from
11 to 1.
oh
we'd walk in 10.59
give us the big table
two dollars give us the whole menu one
shot
give it to us again
the cheeseburgers are delicious
cheeseburgers and they give you like a
shrimp cocktail you just ever go down
the menu
yeah 14 bucks would we still do that
today
if we were that age because or today we
don't do it as much because we we go
home to the internet there's too much
greater or we've quote unquote developed
a character made a career
you know going out like that do people
still go out like that all the time
i think jeff ross goes out quite a bit
women goes out like goes out at night
you know or david tell these guys are
out there at night is there that uh
i don't eat at night
oh you don't smoke pot and i go back to
the hotel room
and i'm pretty happy i'm 54 years old if
i was
42 and single sure i'd go get a bite to
eat and i would talk to people who came
to the show
i'd smoke more dope you know yeah a
little bit more
you know i don't do drugs i don't really
drink right i'm not gonna get sloppy in
public right so it's a different uh
it's a different show but i remember
listen man you think
you're sitting there you're old you
think i need a comedy career
and i gotta tell you something
the highlight of my comedy career was
that
that one year and a half in seattle
that really
let me know
who i was and what i needed to do
new york
let me know how much work it was gonna
give me to
become a comic
this going to seattle
made me realize how much work it was
going to be to kick it up to the next
level which was feature act
i was going to skip over mc
and go right to the feed track i was
already featuring for triple and one
night is why am i
got a mc
you know what i'm saying and everybody
said no call whatever i refused
and i finally got a feature spot
at this comedy underground opening up
for laurie kilmartin
who's still around labor day weekend are
you [ __ ] kidding me or what that was
the highlight of my life for two hundred
dollars
it was fifty dollars a set
good gig
200 at
the comedy underground though i
apologize if you
if you've talked about this before i
think you might have
but i know how you have like your
notebook with everything that you do
do you have like do you have like
years and years of all your gigs that
you've done yeah
jesus i have tons of cassette tapes from
see i went to new york also once i went
to new york and joey told me to go to
new york
and once i went to new york i kind of i
didn't look back on seattle you know i
look back fondly on seattle as i get
older now
more so even though i just i just do
i've always had fondness for it but i
also have fondness for that new york
comedy scene i could really spread my
wings there you know you're staying up
to four or five in the morning you know
i'm doing the tour guide stuff i had to
go to new york
and prove to myself could i be funny on
the east coast can i be funny in some of
the toughest crowds
tough people
and i i and i was able to do it not but
i wasn't
i wasn't uh you know i did late night
spots at standup new york but i had no
confidence to uh you know ask este at
the comedy cellar because i barked there
i was barking i could have been the next
uh you know uh
jim
no who was uh
uh what's brody stevens no but no the
guy who uh lee
i'll think of his name but he moved uh
he would he ran the uh he was the emc
then he moved uh he did uh the boston
comedy club and then he moved to forget
his name but also brother
just the fact that we're still here
in the arena comedy
just thrills me i don't even give a [ __ ]
about that but
i do
really cherish
that comedy zone that comedy scene up
there remember we used on mondays
we leave the underground and go to a
place that was fancy and they had cages
and [ __ ]
and we did comedy there a few times i
don't think we went back because they
wouldn't give us money
and then we started going to tacoma and
doing the comedy crossroads whatever
that was for that chick in fact she
became my friend on facebook and sent me
susan jones yes
nice lady yeah i went to that contest
many a night with zero on my gas tank
yeah and zero in my pocket and left that
with a yardstick and the host
for the following week to pick up a
small yardstick that was uh at the the
crossroads ken ryan god are you [ __ ]
kidding me people
you know what it's like to drive to a
contest
knowing you have to win to get the yard
stick and if you win you get a yard
stick to next week
then you come back the next week and if
you win again
you get the yardstick you keep getting
the [ __ ] yardstick i would take time
off and go down there with three new
minutes and [ __ ] blast them and then
take another month off and blast and
get them for two hours every like six
weeks
seattle was just great for development i
just feel like in arizona i never had
that never had that uh energy for it
just wasn't there but seattle seattle is
just so much to chew on
so green so wet
so and look at all the creativeness
that's come out of seattle amazon costco
um
some other things but microsoft
microsoft red robin a lot of things came
out of seattle space needle
you know um i can't believe that three
of us are still
[ __ ] here
doing stand-up if you told me in
1997 shut your mouth stop busting bro
these balls
he's gonna be doing a podcast with you
in a studio and [ __ ] studio city some
night i'm gonna go are you crazy
probably you'll be playing baseball
somewhere so yeah
i thought this was like a shortcut for
you
until you told me your life story and
then
uh we [ __ ] uh
you you went to new york and you
actually did it and
people said you were out there like
connected with you on the phone or some
[ __ ]
just get what a crazy ride comedy has
been
it's been fun i still have fun
i l you know that's one thing when i
have my spot at the comedy store
i'm always excited about it i mean i me
personally
i just when that day comes when i'm not
into it
you know it's a
and i knew it right away when i was
taking that workshop at ucla i was
excited to go it was that was the you
know what i was into and same thing with
uh seattle the open mics the cable
access i just pushed it you know i sold
t-shirts for the seattle supersonics i
had to train myself so but i learned
from we were so lucky though we were
learning in seattle
non-showcase comedy we were out of la we
learned about opener middle road
corporate clean
um how to you know how clubs ran
you know corp guys taking cruise ships
so that was that was a great scene you
know another funny night of comedy
in seattle
and people i don't have a lot of these i
had one night in boston with stan hope
one night in boston with seattle
and one night
oh
don't hold me to the names people
but there was a town
like where josh wolf had his old
apartment there was a strip club there
where north gate he was up north it was
something he had a house
that was like north korea like aurora
or something so up there
there was a restaurant owned by like a
greek guy
all right and he wanted to do comedy on
wednesday nights
and we would go up there but the night
would always end because somebody would
curse on stage
he would go
totally insanely
do you remember this or you were gone by
the way i i didn't do that one so okay
so we would go up there like once a
month like 16 of us would invade that
place and
count hopkins the third count guys like
that right wally glenn chas
yeah jazzy ramona what what kind of
acting count hopkins
oh oh and it was hysterical because
kevin hopkins iii was a black dude i
figured that was
a great guy he was my friend i wish i
was like a white guys he was basically
purple
like when you hear that expression about
black like when he'd open up his mouth
it would be pink and his skin would this
i mean it was he was one of the darkest
brothers
you'd ever see in his life now
kevin hopkins was like a the third a
feature cannot happen the third was like
a feature act
at the same time i'm dear friends
with a headliner named rod long
now ron long is a seattle native
worked hard all his life
did jesus christ brody steve you know
why i'll tell you what a young [ __ ]
man
i'll tell you why joey because when i
drove up here today yeah i i took a red
bull so red bull makes me take a little
bit
unbelievable we're gonna live with the
young man i'm not this is what this
cholesterol medication is that's why i
said you gotta go to that thyroid doctor
your thyroid's all [ __ ] up
so
this guy was a black dude
that was light-skinned brother
very articulate
great joke writer okay all right always
wore a suit
great guy just knew his marijuana was a
great photographer i loved him so today
i got his phone number in my
in my [ __ ] phone and i still adore
him and
i learned a lot of comedy from him we
drove from
california to
seattle a few times me and him drove
from seattle california and back three
times
just to showcase for [ __ ] that's how
tight we were and he always took good
care of me so i always think about him
and uh he had a family and [ __ ] but
to make a long story short
ra long comes up to me one night now
again you just know me five years but
you have to learn the mind of uncle joey
right right alone from dutchman he goes
you know this [ __ ] black dude
kevin hopkins is the third
and i go yeah i know i guess when he
does comedy you watch him is he doing my
jokes what and i'm like i don't know how
dare he
that's it once you tell me that i'm
gonna feel fired
so okay so let's say
so
when someone comes to you with their
problems
you see it as a way to torture them
mentally into their brains no because
somebody came to me and said
my god [ __ ] rod long is really pissed
at count hopkins the third
right
you know and i was like really
and like oh my god he's [ __ ] furious
trouble in the kingdom that kind of
happens the third
so i would get him fired up about kyle
hopkins a third
what's going on every time i saw him for
about
for about two months
every time i saw him i'd say right along
what's going on what kind of happens a
third [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] oh he
would just go off
for like three or four minutes
that black ass [ __ ] stole my
joke and [ __ ] oh my god
so now i got him going
i got him going like for three months
everything and then one day he figured
out i could see ron long looking at me
he's like why are you always asking me
about god
i don't know i don't see him i don't see
you
but i was seeing rod at that time
twice a week he was taking me on a
couple
gigs you know local donna richards
yeah he did all the sports gigs yes
i wouldn't do those of them those had to
be clean but those are his big corporate
guys he was like one of the go-to guys
for the seahawks
great living yeah that was amazing yeah
and he had a big a good day gig
like
he did cal he did like work yes yes on
the roads he was very fortunate man
so
you know
no mate cliff barnes was that guy cliff
barnes was barnes was a guy he's another
great sweetheart of a dude i really
remember him well me too great guy and
so it was right along rod long but right
long every time i'd see him run along
have a couple cocktails and i'm like a
roll along
what's going on with kel hopkins after
he started him again that motherfucker's
doing my jokes
i'm telling you so now
i would [ __ ] uh wait till friday
night like one in the morning
and i'd call rod long on his cell phone
and if he didn't answer the phone
i go right along pick it up
i go cut out because it's down here and
then i hang up right
were you with your friends or
were you just buying yourself by myself
oh my god i'm by myself in those days
coked up to the gills
just sitting there trying to laugh at
something you know and that's what i
would do toward men oh my god ron long
rod long lived for a year of me
tormenting him not once
was he out of the same night with kyle
hopkins the third
you would just say he was
i would just make up [ __ ] to ride along
when he was home and he couldn't leave
i'd say right ron hurry up
like if i talked to rod in the daytime
and he'd go man
i got a babysitter my wife got something
till midnight i knew i couldn't leave
the house at midnight
so i would call him about ten and go yo
[ __ ] count out because he's down here
doing your material no oh wow that black
[ __ ] better not be doing my
material he would go
off
because he was a little buzzed
who
rod long no rob would be stressing out
with his kids he hated the thought
of somebody john hopkins doing his
material but tom hopkins had never done
his materials i heard so you started
that no i did not start that rod long
started on himself i was taking the holy
eye i messed up him and i let him on
fire he didn't i never ever
said to him i saw count hopkins stealing
material
i always egged them on in a weird way i
don't know what about al fox that was
funny he got pissed
al fox was that was that was funny
you know that at that point i was doing
comedy
four years seriously
two and a half years okay people
let me tell you what happened i went to
an open mic up in seattle
and they put me up like number two
i have it on video somewhere i got like
three minutes no you know
i don't know something uh no i don't but
oh yeah you have the video
so uh
i went there i was like number three
and i got to be honest with you people
i thought i was doing the right move
at that time again i wasn't sure
if i was gonna stay in seattle i had a
daughter in boulder
i had been gone for about two weeks at
this point
my rent was paid till september that and
make up my mind till september pretty
much
the relationship in boulder wasn't going
anywhere and here i am up in seattle
i got a you know
a piece of ass that's a dirty [ __ ]
you know and i'm going through hell
but i'm [ __ ] doing comedy yeah
at not a great comedy club
but one of the best comedy clubs in the
[ __ ] country comedy underground and
i'm living in the music capital of the
[ __ ] world coffee
and coffee coffee i didn't drink coffee
in those days i was eating teriyaki up
at that [ __ ] place number one
teriyaki number one teriyaki that was my
spot
till this day she cut the chicken with
scissors yeah till this day i compared
everything to up there oh that was the
[ __ ] salad dressing oh yeah like the
salad dressing like a tangy it's the
same one that everybody else has but
they did it different and they'd slice
those cucumbers real thin they were the
first people to slice cucumbers
really [ __ ] thin they were
professionals a to z
20 [ __ ] years ago you understand me
it was so good
ball of rice it was all days it was
shameful because i'd be in that three
times in a day
to go box
box i'd eat half of it there i put that
red sauce on it takoyaki and i'd [ __ ]
walk it over to the underground eat it
downstairs
downstairs or in the back yeah
[ __ ] yeah we would eat in the back
build the bartender he was great with
his laugh
but oh i know what i was telling you so
here i am number three i got all these
problems
and i'm sitting here about to watch
the rest of this comedy show in those
days he would put up 17 18 comics yeah
the last guy did 15 or 12. the week
weekly the weather
on monday night no no
the guy was just it could have been you
but he believed in your call okay so
that's how carl did so
that first monday i'm sitting there guys
and i'm waiting to see
comedy brilliance
i am waiting to see
why i'm leaving my life in boulder
i am as excited as can be i just been on
the road for two weeks on the triple run
brodie those are those are tough right
the triple ones at that time yeah
through the first triple run road game
it was two weeks of learning everything
a to z
you know how to eat what how much money
i could spend
you know i didn't really ask for drugs
in those days i was winging it in those
days
um it was a different scenario but
i'll never forget number four
was that kid who killed himself
jeff master what's a half cup god bless
his soul
but as soon as he went on stage brother
you knew it was a mental health problem
like the three guys after me
had mental health issues and if you
didn't know that
who were they i didn't come on i don't
remember now
no no rita was in that neighborhood
rita was in that name but also
but from four to like eight it was just
people that were
they came down every week
they went up three to four weeks
they didn't write a new joke
they didn't want to write a joke
and this is what they did every week and
they had a day job
and they didn't do gigs for certain
reasons
and it was very
like i would sit there and go who would
come down here monday night put up with
this abuse
to do
six minutes and not be a professional
comedian
like i learned so i remember being down
there one night
and everybody was so high on heroin
dog the waitresses were not
the asian hot one that dated that dude
with the long hair
and and the bartender there's a real
real pretty girl of the blonde i forget
her name come on dog i was in that place
in the summer in 96 and those
[ __ ] were nodding on a monday
night
you couldn't get a drink in there
because the wait wait staff was high on
[ __ ] heroin i didn't realize that
what did the customers think the
customers were just sitting there
waiting for [ __ ] something to happen
we would get crowds for the open mics
that's the thing monday and tuesday
monday and tuesday they get anywhere
from 60
to 100 people open mic i got to be
honest with you guys about six years ago
i was going through tapes when we were
moving into the valley
and i saw this tape and i threw it in
and it was a melody of tapes upset that
i had taped over the years
and guess what came up
a monday night in seattle
and in those days we had six minutes
and it was a monday night
and at this time again in my life i was
living through a personal health
yes i had a girlfriend that was pretty
yes sweet 69 and do dirty dirty dirty
things oh
but she was a [ __ ]
and i was crazy it's not a good
combination
what the [ __ ] am i talking about you're
talking about seattle your life up there
what was going on because i'll tell you
what
thank god we went to seattle like we
said mitch hedberg was up there people
knew no a bunch of [ __ ] people were
they all came up all the san francisco
comics they came up there they got it
margaret cho janine garofalo
pat naswal i met so many [ __ ] people
we were learning seattle and so many
people i was in awe of great speech in
seattle i mean corporate games oh i saw
who else the [ __ ] did i say it was just
seattle was a three-year
college education for me that i thought
i'd never ever have look the truth is
right here this is 20 [ __ ] years
later he's sitting right in front of me
i'll tell you i was uh i was an
internship at cairo sports i wanted to
learn about sports radio i i had already
graduated from arizona state i wanted to
be an intern so i signed up for a class
at bellevue community college to be an
intern for cairo cbs sports i go down to
the mariner games interview the players
and i did a couple stand-up sports like
hi everybody i'm stephen brody reporting
live from the kingdome but it just
wasn't my thing
being brody doing that cable access show
getting on stage and ranting and that's
when you said
go to new york and i went to new york
and i went down to the lower east side
and i did surf reality where they didn't
want jokes they wanted you they wanted
craziness they wanted drumming
and i broke through and i did that
really found my voice didn't look back
on seattle and then the tour guide stuff
it just you know you gotta live in new
york it's like you gotta wait tables you
gotta live in new york you gotta take
public transportation you gotta be
around all different people now look the
world's crazy right now i don't know if
those rules still apply
but
for growing up in the valley yes i
always wanted to go to new york just
like growing up watching
wor met games it was just something
about the yankees i'd come play anaheim
stadium and it was just new york i knew
i had to go to new york and then my
friend got the job with the yankees
borzello and it's like now i get to hang
out with the yankees get to go to yankee
stadium but i wasn't there to go to
yankee stadium you know and i did have
pressure like oh why don't you come to
the yankee games it's like i got to go
to surf reality i got to go to standup
new york i got to go to gotham and get
on stage
so
but i experienced new york and
it all that stuff seattle and it just
got me ready for la and well seattle to
you
was new york to me my brother see there
you go you just as you were talking you
just said something to me oh i was in
new york for nine months
and i went to new york
let's be honest i went for three reasons
i went to
get away from what i had going on in
boulder okay i went to
hook up with this girl that was
phenomenal
good as the third number three though
was county but with a tight four was
doing cocaine and getting up at 20 a
gram in harlem
so i went back to [ __ ] new york and
uh new york to me was seattle to you i
did a couple things not tv nothing right
but i was getting spots yeah and i was
going to new york comedy club he liked
me so he put me up like bomb
i was just a [ __ ] bomb machine then
and one day i went into yellow triple in
yep on 54th at night i saw john
leguizamo at two in the morning and i
left that it hit me like a bag of bricks
and i said i'll go to colorado and do
this dirty work
well and that was my plan i went to
colorado and did that dirty work only in
colorado well why why did that why did
john leguizamo at that moment why did
that make you want to go to back to
boulder
because i thought
now i understood what comedy was
for a long time i thought that
i'd call brodie this is this is you know
and i talked about this before
this is how i'm naive i was about kami
so i thought comedy was always like hey
lee
who's your favorite comedian i love
brother stevens
why do you like him he's jewish he's
nervous i love about these things right
thank you call up brodie stephen's agent
and call him and see what he's doing
tonight
that's what i thought connie was
and they would call you up and they'd
say brother you're available to shoot
tonight
well what's the take to take his 30
minutes
hbo whatever that's how i thought
stand-up was wow and then uh
and then [ __ ] whatever your name is
you came down there
you went on stage you did your album
very casually like this isn't the top of
your head when i put that's how [ __ ]
we taught it and drugged up and out of
prison i got into it thinking okay
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to go on stage maybe 10 times
and on the 10th time somebody's gonna
see me
and that's gonna be it i don't have to
do another [ __ ] that other people have
to do right so i was going out to comedy
clubs at night
in the back of my mind going look at
these peasants
peasants you know what i'm saying
they're doing it all wrong i got it all
right street smart i'm gonna energy i'm
gonna do this in 10 minutes and get the
[ __ ] out of here
and that's what i would do i would do it
in 10 minutes get the [ __ ] out
it was just something that uh but i
failed
as a new york comedian
like i couldn't do
what regular people were doing in new
york that was too much movement for me
at that
yeah i liked going out to maybe two
places once you started making me go to
staten island in queens
without a car like i got a call one time
i'm in atlantic city in crab legs with
my boy jimmy berkel just god say rich's
soul
and we're going call at five o'clock to
be in
whatever [ __ ] connecticut
at eight o'clock at this moose bar
and we drove up there right away and we
made it just in time
and you know we did the smoosh ball
whether they pay a buck and a quarter
whatever you know
i like that type of adventure
right i was [ __ ] single
my comedy career would be completely
different i'd be working
six nights a week
clean and sober how i am now only his
reefer on the road yeah there's tons of
reefer on the road
i would get a bus get my man lee here
let me sleep in the [ __ ] chairs
i would turn this bedroom into a studio
for podcasting oh gee thanks and the
podcast from the van
yeah that's it for me when what brought
me back to la i knew i wanted to come
back when i was 30. but doing these
shows downtown got a chance to host a
couple and dave chappelle was on and
todd barry and mark maron and i was kind
of holding my own i was holding my own i
was doing okay i didn't bring the show
down
so i was hosting that i did a couple
spots and at that point i felt like it
was the summer time my apartment was hot
it wasn't
you know it's funny i mean i knew i
could do i knew going because my friends
that i met in new york they're all
moving to la to work on these tv shows
so they were working at these late night
tv shows and they and they told me like
i had a chance to get on them
and once i did some of those shows at
luna lounge on the monday night those
hip shows because i was doing late night
spots at the comedy clubs but i wasn't
ready for those prime timers yet how did
you react to winters at first brody they
didn't bother me because i went to
seattle
i went to seattle and kind of prepped me
for it that's why i knew the reason why
i went to seattle is because i have
aunts and uncles and cousins up there
and i went up there in like 1980 so i
just remember
going to seeing the mariners
and
going to the jewish community center and
seeing the supersonics work out their
line there that was that was when they
were winning freddie johnson down you
know gus
williams
why were they using the jcc that's where
they worked out they worked out at the
jewish community center
maurice lucas i think was there so i i
fell in love with seattle i knew what
was up there and then when i played
baseball my freshman year so this is
1989
i went up to alaska to play baseball in
the summertime 24-hour daylight up in
alaska
and we worked our way down to british
columbia and i just remember driving
through british columbia how beautiful
was how green it was how um the
mountains i just loved it
and then i spent
i spent about um
maybe like a week in seattle with my
aunts and uncles and i just felt the
vibe there and that's when i started
listening to nirvana i remember
listening to nirvana and flying out to
seattle and then that whole scenes the
grunge scene started in 91 you know a
pearl jam and sound garden so i knew
there was some kind of energy up there
put it in my back pocket and then when i
was done with school
we had the northridge earthquake i was
working at macy's out at topanga plaza
you know selling china on the fourth
floor
spinning my wheels living up in the
hills with berzello you know just like
to start here is almost impossible i
mean i mean it's different now it's
different now but back then
i didn't have the support system you
know i'm living out in the valley i i i
had no
that's why i went to i took a workshop
let me describe for people
what it's like it's like
the only comparison we could describe to
you is
doing comedy here in l.a
if you start here in l.a oh god that's
not it's not good because your mental
state is even different because
everybody's talking about comedy yes
with the final end already you being on
tv when you start in michigan which i
love to use as an example because they
have such a huge state
so they have all these little like flint
and all these little cities they do
comedy in because in the winter there
ain't dick to do they do kind you could
make you could start as an mc in
michigan went to the comedy scene what
comedy scene what's that flint
they all do pop up the map of [ __ ]
michigan and let's i'll tell you how
many comedy clubs there are michigan
just without me even looking at the
comedy club list you know okay this is
how [ __ ] bad to the bone i am i will
tell you and if i'm lying to you type me
back and say oh the comedy club closed
there
that's how many clubs
there are in michigan it's a big state
if you want to start comedy and you
don't want to be seen you either go to
mission you either go to michigan
or texas
that's where you go for three years if
you don't like austin
you go to austin or houston you travel
all through the state of texas
you're always moving through the state
of texas you're doing bars there's so
many [ __ ] comedy holes in texas
that you cannot even [ __ ] imagine
like
map of michigan with the names of it
all those little cities guys
have [ __ ] comedy i can't see [ __ ]
and joey this has nothing to do with
like best damn sports show you're
talking stand-up comedy did doing best
damn sports show help you as a stand-up
comedian being on live you know live the
tape
so many times there and knocking it out
every time did that help at all with
stand-up comedy or this is something
completely different
other than maybe just
the best damn sports show
was [ __ ] great experience
because it was me in front of a camera
did anybody watch that [ __ ] thing
i have no idea i think they did grand
travis says michigan
keeps has comedy euron has comedy
saginaw has come kalamazoo kalamazoo
grand rapids muskegon has comedy detroit
st claire has comedy
keep going up these are just the
counties the other way the other way gee
these are the other way no what are you
going into the ocean
oh that's the right that's like michigan
the other way the other way all that
little island upper p.i upper p.i there
the uh
what the [ __ ] do that
mean
michigan militia all right go down
scroll down my friend marquette
that's a different market
mackinac
island with that kid from seattle stu
stewart would go out there ran like a
comedy show right there so you can see
everything good memories there you go
but these are skills my friend i know
keep going but all these counties have
michigan and these are the ones
we [ __ ] know of
think of all the st joseph's
all that niles
all that by uh it's called mitchell
walker
all those places have some sort of
economy yeah go look at a map of
michigan by this
by the city but you know what that says
joey told me he said you know go away
for six months and then come back go out
on the road stay out of la
and then they'll see your growth you
know you got to come back and forth you
got to leave and come back a monster
yeah you got it's like if you were going
to do steroids how would you do steroids
you'd sit in front of these people that
you've been around all your life
doing steroids and they wouldn't even
notice you
they would say something looks different
about you you disappear for eight months
you promise yourself
you know what you have a cousin his name
is lee
he goes to college in boston oh he told
you he'd get you a job in uh the coffee
shop at the university
and you could scratch at his floor
boom that's it
you know why your cousin's going early
because he read over the year about all
the great comics that came out of boston
because that was a that was a fantastic
that's a fantastic scene so you have
this [ __ ] dream as a young comic
and all of a sudden you got a cousin who
goes to college in boston
and you're like 28 you know you could
still fit in and it's not like joey
knocking on your door hey
let me sleep on your floor no
it's somebody who's your age let me tell
you something man
you do complete all that type of [ __ ] i
agree with all that type of stuff
especially in the beginning
especially beginning you find the cousin
or something
you look at the map good
and they have two comedy clubs and the
one-nighter
that's what it shows you that means
there has to be
four open mics
but the only way you're gonna know
is by getting on the bus and going there
you're not going to find that in your
house it's not going to tell you
when you go out to that comedy club
people are going to go to you what are
you doing tuesday night
nothing what they do comedy rusty nail
from 8 to 10 and then we go over to
malacca's and they give you a hundred
dollars a piece
boom i know what i'm doing tuesday night
and all of a sudden when you get there
tuesday they're like what are you doing
tomorrow night we do the vfw
it's only 35 bucks a set but it's better
than nothing
boom there you go you got to go out to
me you got to go out the [ __ ] metal
you still do right at the at the you
know comedy
it's
human it's emotion you have to there's
no
it really isn't a shortcut the bottom
line is you got to go out on the road
but it's changed a little bit now with
the internet it's like these guys could
study comedy really
study it visualize it like become these
you know you can find your voice quicker
these days would you say
i think you could find your voice
and the amount of time you like
let me explain something to you
my first
year and a half
i watched so much stand-up comedy
i rented the tape so many times
from the video store that the guy
wouldn't even charge me anymore
the bet no no the hbo what was it death
comedy yeah
all stars
but the most important ones was rodney
dangerfield yeah bro dice with dice and
picks and
roseanne there was two tape series
that drove me crazy
that's all i want over and over and i
made notes
like a football coach and i looked at
their mannerisms
and that's all i wanted to be
for christ's sake people don't remember
that feeling anymore you know it's like
and you didn't want to tell people you
still got that job over with the car
like yet
you don't want to go into it because
people are going to try to tell you a
stand-up camera you ain't that funny i
had you at my house that day yeah
well you're right over there yeah my
butt was right in the top your butt was
ready you ready for another start no
wonder how many stars you thought i
didn't even count you ate four i know
but i i at least six
oh no that's suspect see i was so
focused on baseball and people you know
i just never was did the arts never was
into my mom you know we didn't push we
push baseball i like throwing i like the
structure of little league and i just
kept always i never was like a performer
for i did some from silly performances
and then just playing baseball just
goofy faces and stuff and then later on
people would say rudy you're funny you
they told me i was funny i never like
told people i was funny i was afraid of
the ball like i was fine throwing it i
still am i
me too yeah i don't wanna i got hit one
i guess i got i was playing catch and
hit me in the face
that's well
i mean i've been hitting my eye through
the sun i've been uh line drives back
i'm not afraid of catching the ball but
like fielding the ball or like yeah if a
pitcher's throwing 95 miles an hour but
i was a pretty good pitcher i got i feel
like i have no bitterness on my baseball
i felt like i got the most out of it
and
even to this day you can still be around
major leaguers you don't have to pitch
in the game you can still
you know
i tell people it's like i visualize
stuff if you visualize it it could
happen you know i visualized
being able to do a few things there's
something to that like whether you call
meditation or
i was a visualizing dog when i wanted to
realize that i want to become a comic
you just did it i focused
on blow
and getting on [ __ ] stage and writing
stupid [ __ ] jokes
backed by energy and anger from this
chick i was driving and my divorce and
how broke i was
so it worked
you know and i didn't believe in seattle
a [ __ ]
okay comic i thought
and then i went to a couple places in
l.a
and i was like you know what i may be
betting a little okay and that's when
you blew up like you were no and then i
went to the improv and stuff and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
this is real
at that time i had done road work i'm
not gonna lie i did a bunch of triple
work i had done donna richards work i
had gone to spokane
where taylor's karate buddy i had gone
to [ __ ] portland moscow bellingham
moscow idaho i'd gone to all these
things
i'd gone to florida for a week i was i
knew the road was like the king of the
road was like staying up at the time not
at all
and what the [ __ ] happened cause i lose
my [ __ ] training daughter no you're
on the road you're the king of the road
then you come to l.a
and that comedy store doing that being
there late night when it was free that
was [ __ ] me up that was [ __ ] my
confidence up then i started picking a
little bit of momentum up i'll go latino
night and i would do little cheat things
talk in spanish and i'd blow up the room
and i'd go to the comedy store late
night and i'd go on a rant why is that
cheating
yeah
little things you could do and then it's
like going out there and saying you want
to applaud for the troops
oh [ __ ] like that and then um
i went to the improv one night
at that time i had a manager that kept
pushing road work on me
and i was like i don't know and it was
flat fee type of [ __ ]
no hotel some of it was hotel
some of it was just come on down and
showcase for us
but let me tell you about what happened
with him
tell me to remind you later what
happened with this guy so
in this trip i had signed with him
like in february i had been here maybe
three weeks
the first time when i got here from
seattle i signed with him
and that summer i said listen
i'm in new york i'm going to go back
there and do comedy he got me a couple
little gigs here and there camacho giggs
and
roger paul
uh no at that time uh
new york rascals rascals vinnie brandt
uh
no at that time
i hadn't worked with any brand i had
done a few one-nighters
up north or some [ __ ] like that see you
through my [ __ ] train of thought
sorry about that bring it back no crazy
no no worries
what the [ __ ] was i talking about
going on oh and he [ __ ] sent me to
governors
he sent me i can't remember to like four
or five clubs he did a great job and
i'll tell you what else he did
he goes listen
go to this address
and i go what's this address he goes i
want you to drop off
a tape are you doing stand-up
to this address
it's a new show
i go what's the name of it give me and
just he goes
to soprano and i kept whoa
yeah these guys singers
i don't want to be a [ __ ] singer
i had never dropped off the tape you
didn't this was before the
this was before the casting you would
have probably in new york for sure
i wasn't ready i was green i had the
opportunity to hear later and i ate a
bag of [ __ ]
so you did have an opportunity i read
for them early on the first the end of
the first season
when they were soprano mania yeah right
then and then i got an audition
okay then they made me audition maybe
i'll dish it for two or three different
guys gg stone
the undercover cop season two
and there was somebody else they're
making me audition for did you ever take
acting classes at that time anywhere
at that time absolutely
when i came to l.a
i think it took me a year to finally
change my thing and i started going that
december i saw you in baseball
at that time i was not an acting class
that's a classic movie
is it really basketball
yeah yeah it's kind of like a cult
classic and you're in it
does anyone ever bring that up to you
every once in a while you're a referee
in it somebody puts a picture up
of me ref and on twitter they go look
who we just saw on twitter
on
um
basketball baseball
i mean that's pretty cool then you were
even spider-man also
a couple years after that
i just bumped into sam raymond he had a
a pitch
sam raimi he directed for love of the
game the baseball movie
really yeah the one with kevin costner
sam raimi directed it my friend
brazzello who's with the yankees so that
movie was filmed probably in 98 or 99 at
yankee stadium
um and john c riley was in it kevin
costner and it was about kevin costner
throwing a no-hitter and flashing back
on his life
so
um
john c reilly was cast in the movie he
was the catcher
but he wasn't that great at baseball and
they gave him like a brand new baseball
glove and though he couldn't catch he
like couldn't do the scenes and costner
would get upset sam raimi was a director
but basically costner did everything so
he gave him this glove he couldn't catch
borzella was there kind of like
um
being uh helping out a little bit like
just
helping them with uh consulting yeah
exactly he was there for that
and then they said um you know what you
look like uh john c reilly and priscilla
was a bullpen catcher so they had
brazillo play john c reilly all the
baseball scenes had him shave his arms
so if you watch for love of the game
which is still like a baseball movie
that holds water or you know it still
plays on mlb network if you watch the
baseball scenes
john c reilly who's the catcher in the
movie it's berzello back there if you
look you can tell and he's the coach now
with the with the cubs he went on to win
five world series championships that's
another thing it's about winning you got
to push i grew up here in the valley i
learned about pushing believing you know
and it's like it's such a
this world now again i don't want to
harp on politics but i'm a single white
guy i'm i'm there
you know i don't have uh i get pushed
around a little bit i see it grew up
here in the valley people put the valley
down
but i don't know i threw that in but the
bottom i see the american flag i like
that you know
it's just uh it's a crazy time and i
feel like
certain tweets you gotta watch what you
say because this town's based off like
uh
reputation you know certain actors
they're in the same thing because they
all think the same but i feel like
you know you talk about living in your
car and believing in yourself you know
this is a great time to be a comedian
you know there's so much stuff out there
just go for it that's why i think
you could do this plan
we could sit down during the week
a rv there's a national company that
finances you
if we could do a show
or figure out a way to tweet
with their rv something there's a hook
there for nashville i like that right
there i like that right there across
country trip with brody you know your
periscope is very big
there's no reason why you can't add ads
to the periscope make a little money
there
i need a new manager i think you would
be a great manager
oh yeah he'd be the best man why don't
you manage me really because i got
enough [ __ ] on my plate
lee well he doesn't know whether he
wants to go to pismo beach
or a [ __ ] long beach for a honeymoon
but you guys don't understand joey's
giving me you know it's like joey does
his own stuff these guys do a lot of
their thing you know but i want you to
understand like
a lot a lot of my career choices a lot
of fundamentals that i go to are based
off joey diaz based off that and also in
terms of confidence
back in like 2001 having joe rogan say
you're funny so that kind of like helped
me relax and go for it and push a little
bit knowing that rogan thought i was
funny and he asked me i did the audience
warm-up you know for uh the man show
with stan hope and rogan
and uh they gave me the confidence you
know i kind of rode that but i was so
good at audience warm-up i just
continued doing
audience warm-up i got too good at it
that was the problem
well it's an important part of the show
and i like however i i
i hear sorry i've seen you once and it's
still the one thing that the room just
moved yeah joey's having a good time you
know i'm i'm hanging in there you guys
had a little more than me but i'm
hanging in there let me open the door
i'll take a little peep piece hold on
one second okay ooh the room just moved
like there was an earthquake uncle joey
had to catch himself he fell asleep
there for a minute or something
chocolate bar
you okay
so del destino so lee yes sir you've
seen audience warm-up you've seen you
saw my stand-up recently that was a
great feeling to be at the comedy store
that night and then i saw you over on
the left-hand side but i wasn't sure
if it was you
and then uh you know i had a pretty good
set and then for you to you know you
came you've been very supportive of my
comedy i think you're i think you're
very funny i am uh
especially when i i really like
my favorite kind of comedy is like the
hour but i do like going to the comedy
store right you get a lot of variety
you get a lot of variety but if you if
you sit there
from
ten or nine and then you're there at 12
30 or one right so most of the regular
stuff is pretty boring just to see you
is always very exciting and then i just
you're
like your instagram is
like this
you have inside jokes with people
if they've seen the brody stephen's
instagram because you have to see it you
can't just watch it one day
yeah are you talking about like the
instagram stories inside yeah i like
your instagram stories that's right yeah
because they used to watch it like every
day
and the little theme the more you want
yeah i i really like the uh the dirty
newspaper yeah the newspaper kills me
and uh
what else yes
i don't use periscope as much watching
it just i don't have time to sit there
watching it but i miss you drumming yeah
i need a drum more but you know
instagram's quick and easy i keep it
positive you know it's twitter you can
be negative i feel like it's kind of
hard to be negative on instagram i'm not
verified that upsets me but you're still
mad at them yeah you know it it's uh it
bothers me no i'm really um
i'm not mad i'm happy with my uh
what's great about this is like
you know
it's good that i'm out here because lee
your respected guy you're supportive i
got guys you know the ari shafir crew
all those guys everyone's there so i
need to take action like tonight joey
reached out i've been putting out the
energy focusing some nights i'm not
getting those spots
but i'm pushing it but i'm going on the
road too i'm going to iowa i'm going to
doing shows in a tent and i like doing
it you know i just got to make a few
bucks that's my thing i don't need to
have a house i don't need i'm okay with
uh you know give me a little internet
give me good water pressure
a vehicle that i can sleep in i guess
we're going there but uh
i like the baseball stuff i'm getting to
if i can combine sports my love and i
will be they're tough to get a dime out
of they are and even when you get the
dime out of it it's not the best dime in
the world
there's too many restrictions
to take the small michael but you know
would be a great job joey to work in
baseball as a positive energy coach they
need positive energy around these teams
they need a friend they need somebody
who understands comedy who can tell them
how to be how to be um funny when they
do their interviews and also
not say weird stuff keep the guys light
i also played baseball and i know how to
throw a ball
i wouldn't mind getting involved in
baseball because hollywood is so
you know turbulent right now lee do you
think so
i mean there's always i'm always
surprised uh
especially with sports teams that they
allow them to have social media twitter
i understand why they why they have to
because they have to brand market
themselves i got a plan for you but they
always seem to get it joey does have a
plan
okay we're right here we go you want to
start your journey yep
number one you have to apply yourself to
a player
you have to look at the end of the year
this baseball season
and see what player had a
mediocre play-off when he could have a
tremendous player yeah and you
hook him up on twitter
and you know my name is brodie stevens
i'm a palmer comedian but my main source
of energy is i'm a positive energy coach
i love to come work with you
and you all on my expense this will cost
you nothing oh if at the end of the
season
you know a better player then you decide
i'll make you
sign the contract even if you just give
me 25 000 at the end of the season
another idea that joey that
you will hit better what would you do
in that
off-season
pre-season
right pre-season training
pre-baseball week away
and baseball to make this play a better
mentally that's right instead of
focusing on a team in terms of getting a
gig reach out to players there's
350 players there's only 30 teams reach
out to the players look at my
credentials i was in the hangover i was
in due date i'm getting decent spots at
the comedy store i can help you become a
better baseball player
give you advice
and i'll put out energy for you and
let's see what happens let's see what i
believe in you if you believe in me i
accept paypal thank you
what a energy
i'll pray for him i'll face mecca and
pray
no i will uh just
psych so psychology i can help them with
breathing i can help them with what i
did
being smart i can i can do that i know
you're like putting me on the spot i'm
not pointing i just want to learn i
could tell them about being i was lost
people want to know what you're doing
how much would 10 sessions cost for
somebody right now if they want if they
lived
in the san fernando valley and they were
struggling they wanted to become a piano
player but something was holding them
back
what would you charge somebody for a 10
week
brodie stevens d
d uh decapitate the enemy within session
how are they what 50 minute sessions
whatever you want to do how long can you
hypnotize somebody on terrorize what are
you thought
i think 50 is the is the the limit i
would say 100 bucks so a package uh of
10 for a thousand
be a thousand for positive but if you
contact brodie right now tonight this
weekend brody brodysievens.com he'll
give you the whole packet for 900.
that's the first 900 joey yeah that's
the first visit that's crazy
that's a hundred
bucks less i want them to get something
because they listen
okay what's the promo code the promo
code is i heard about you on the podcast
i want to know if we could do the deal
for the small nine years okay
it's payment is uh two 450s
where do i meet him
you meet him at the starbucks somewhere
oh they can meet at starbucks sure
that's where you make the initial
confirmation okay but what about after
that the meetings the meetings yeah
that's what i'm saying in your house if
you were in a robe
and they get naked on the bed he was
just a male maybe that's the tournament
i'm trying to do that all right then i
don't [ __ ] know can i meet him at
starbucks you assessed him the first
time you can't you can't do the whole
session at starbucks that's not that's a
lot more like this studio maybe i run
out this studio here's the deal here's
the deal you meet him at starbucks the
first time of course safer then you
assess him and then you call him and the
night before you're supposed to meet him
you meet him somewhere that's gonna
what's the word i'm looking for it's
gonna blow up his century a part a park
that he's never been well see if if i
think park
and you think park it's a bad idea it's
hacky
why the heck we're helping the guy he's
hacking no we gotta take him somewhere
oh oh god really stimulating take him to
the ocean the arcade take him to the zoo
retards light the zoo i'm talking i like
that i haven't been to the zoo for a
while
oh my god you sure that you see what
rogan tweeted today
they threw a [ __ ] donkey into like
the tiger pit why where
because like the people who owned the
zoo
the chinese
investors weren't happy with the uh
profit so they
were trying to steal the donkey and then
they wouldn't let them so they they were
trying to save money on feed does he
have the video of it yeah is it pretty
graphic yeah but it's it's nature
yeah kind of but they said they they fed
them that's not nature what am i telling
you
the zoos in china got those [ __ ]
gorillas dressed up like the beatles
yeah they said they make them perform
but that's funny are they not happy
they're probably not happy they're not
serious in japan and china over there
zoos and [ __ ]
anyway let's [ __ ] cut this off here
probably stevens it's been honored to
watch you grow as a comedian
as a human being
as a good son to your mom a good brother
you know
yeah be a little issue from time to time
or you're solid
and most importantly we're still in this
oh my god boy stevens
it petrifies me sometimes
and petra for sunday night that was
scary
you're following me at the store
if i came up to you 25 20 years ago at
the [ __ ] underground and go right in
20 years of the sunday night you're
gonna follow me at the store
what are the odds you're gonna look at
me and go joey you really need
professional help that's like two high
school baseball players that go you know
what we're gonna be teammates in the
major leagues and i'm gonna hit behind
you one game i'm sitting that night
watching you going wow
i'm getting old
so was brody but we're still here but
we're living longer we're taking
supplements we're drinking water
we're being popular drinking water
pissing stretching sleeping which is
[ __ ] so crucial you know eight hours
go for it i do
so many things now hey listen you can
never cheat your heart your heart's like
the devil you need cardio right it gives
you
just so many [ __ ]
pumps and after that what about apple oh
yeah no more
apple cider vinegar
right joey
it's supposed to be good
no i take it you take apple cider
vinegar i take everything you do apple
cider vinegar
i take apple cider vinegar i've lost you
know i've lost inches whenever i mention
it people get excited about it you look
for them
yeah but i barely exercise
all i do is walk and stretch when i
first met you with chisel
people used to think you were johnny
america yeah but now i've leaned out you
leaned out again you're a savage you
still got the kettlebells yeah but if i
get i gotta i i get hurt if i get back
you know i'm older so i gotta walk
i gotta watch my impact so i should be
spin biking more i should be doing like
iranian griffin canyon more
i should be swimming more swimming
biking
all that stuff spinning swimming he
joined the swim school
where where do you swim at well i
haven't gone there yet but they have one
in burbank swim school yeah they have
classes
you don't know how to swim or is it just
a lap pool
he went last week to place his clothes i
didn't go there um swimming is a great
exercise i need to get back in there be
a savage in the pool i heard when he
swims you're [ __ ] honey molly and
[ __ ] jews are good swimmers my dad was a
good swimmer mark spitz was a good
swimmer jewish i just don't have any
cardio i know how to swim i just can't
do it for very long
i'll do it i have a i need some advice
and i don't know who's if anyone's had
had this issue
i have to go to urologist and they're
going to stick a finger on my butt
is it
i've never had that happen it's no big
deal it's not that bad
no i mean i was reading the newspaper
the other day and they in the back there
no um
have an enema the night before
no it's not bad you know it's like when
it's like wiping your uh thing and then
he'll say like i'm gonna enter it
and then it goes in there and you just
like relax you give in
and uh it'll be over and then how long
does it take like two minutes two
seconds or oh it's a [ __ ] night man
just thinking about that i don't know no
it's like 15 seconds they're just
checking for like polyps or stuff they
put you in the bed
they make you curl up in a fetal
position yeah he sticks his string he
puts a glove on yeah vaseline around
like vaseline
and he rubs your back
and moves
next thing that you feel this thing's
does he rub the back he might sure he
rubs your back and talks to you about
because it helps relax yeah it gets your
mind off of it
oh they've been there have been doing
well and next thing you know you get
this warm finger up your ass and you
feel it he hits like the button where
[ __ ] starts to come out and the worst is
when you look at his glove and he's got
a little bit of [ __ ] on it
that's the worst that's embarrassing
and my doctor wants him to massage the
prostate does he yes i don't know what
that oh you need a little masseuse of
the prostate oh [ __ ]
so that's a part you're gonna splash all
over yourself
you might as well talk say paul over
here
stroke that little penis of death oh
jesus christ
i gotta hate tweet
from who front row brian he goes dawg
you mentioned you played baseball two
dozen times i figured out you played
baseball after a first dozen times you
said it
tremendous well-deserved infamy whatever
there's people like that [ __ ] up and
[ __ ] anyway
let's go very up yeah very oh he's like
a big fan of you he's a good man let's
get the sponsors okay and let's do this
[ __ ] here number one let me explain
something to you
uh
what do you do when you want a snack but
all you can find is junk food
you rely on your self-control
to resist the temptation that never
works so you eat the junk food start
snacking healthy
with nature bucks
let me explain something to you i've had
those chocolate nom noms i had a little
shipment come in
and those trucks and nom noms i know how
to eat them now you gotta eat two of
them and put the rest of them away and
they'll last you some time at first when
i was getting the chocolate nom noms i
was eating a whole bag of gavon because
i was eating like five at a time in one
hand i said i can't do that with the nom
noms they have certain things that are
just tremendous over there but listen i
still haven't tried one nom no i'm don't
worry about nothing i got you covered
nature box makes snacks that actually
taste great and are better for you
created with high quality ingredients
that are free form
free from artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners so you can feel great about
snacking
nature buck recently made their service
even better now you can order as much as
you want as often as you want with no
minimum purchase required and you can
cancel any time you understand me it's
simple go to naturebox.com and check out
their snack catalog
there are over 100 snacks to choose from
and they're constantly adding delicious
new
snacks
choose the snacks you want and they'll
deliver them right from your door let me
just give you some answer right the
vanilla bean wafers are to die for the
lemon almond miscot bites you're gonna
[ __ ] jump out the window how good
they are all right the dark cocoa nom
noms you're gonna want to eat the whole
bag you're gonna need therapy the
toasted sesame street that's the toasted
sesame sticks that's a different level
all right the aged cheddar lentil loops
get ready to kill yourself all right the
south pacific plantains there you go the
garlic bread cheese grips
the salt and vinegar veggie chips the
the salt and pepper lentil loops will
make you want to go out and hit somebody
with the car i mean that's how good this
stuff is you understand me the
strawberry lemonade
the full apple these are all like uh a
cranberry melly of the double berry
fruit peels then you got the cashew
power clusters you got the crispy
coconut squares what's hair what do you
do
you got the pineapple coconut bars
you got the cherry vanilla granola
you got the the the the french vanilla
almond granola which is sensational
and i mean the list goes on and on do
yourself a favor all right go to
naturebox.com right now and you'll save
even more nature box is offering the
church family
the people who listen to the show 50 off
your first order when you go to
naturebox.com
again they're going to take 50
off your first order when you go to
naturebox.com joey that's naturebox.com
joey for 50 off your first order online
naturebox.com
joey healthy snacks right there at your
fingertips start snacking healthy today
number two
let me tell you something when uh the
company called me
they sent me and i don't even know how
to describe it at this point this has
been my first week but everything feels
different
you know but again like i told you in
the beginning of the show here's
something that you want many recent
studies suggest that having good oral
health
impacts your overall health
uh yet most of us don't brush our teeth
properly you can start brushing better
today i'll tell you what i'm gonna
introduce you to it's a product called
quip the new company that's refreshing
the way people brush their teeth
grip is an electric toothbrush that
packs in a premium vibration and timer
features into an ultra slim design
that's half the cost of bulkier brushes
it's basically like the apple designed a
toothbrush but without the big price tag
and you have to see it and brush with it
yourself you could even subscribe to
receive new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three-month plan
for five dollars you understand me
including free shipping quip is backed
by the leading dentist and was named as
one of time magazine's
best inventions of 2016.
they won a 2016 gq grooming award and
they made it in opposed 2017
new year's old list all right quip
starts at 25
what i'm gonna do for you is this
right now go to quip.com
take a look at what you want to look at
you're going to love it once you see
what you want the toothbrush you see how
the whole plant works read about it and
then go back to
and go to quick.com joey and get your
first refill pack free
with equip electric toothbrush you're
gonna you're gonna love it's gonna
change how you brush your teeth that's
your first refill pack free equip.com
joey again
get quipped.com
joey this is the future
okay of brushing your teeth
number three again father's day is
coming you're sitting there what are you
gonna give him a stupid [ __ ] time
what are you gonna get him
shoe polish whatever you take him to the
restaurant that he likes he's gonna eat
the same pride [ __ ] food
[ __ ] that he's sitting there all day and
watching tv he's retiring
he's in that and he's got a little spunk
left to him and he's walking around at
any point he's been your [ __ ] dad
you're a grown person
give your dad something he's really
gonna use get him
a [ __ ] bidet but joey he's a
christian listen
there ain't a christian in the world
that wants a dirty [ __ ] you
understand me nobody wants to walk
around with a dirty [ __ ] there's
nothing like sitting down
turning around
going in the bathroom before you go to
the bathroom you feel something weird
you're wiping the toilet paper is brown
you've been walking like that all day
what do you think happens after three
hours there's a certain stench on your
back you understand me but that ends
right now
go to hellotushy.com you know what
hellotushy.com is they have portable
bidet snaps right into your bathroom
right in your house you'll never have a
stinky [ __ ] again let's pretend you
wake up in the morning your little pep
in your step listen you get a coffee you
get a little nicotine gum you do three
bangets you sit in that [ __ ]
hellotushy.com and let that water
vibrate the center of your body and
what's that joey your [ __ ] because
there ain't nothing like kicking your
ass on your [ __ ] at [ __ ] five in
the morning that wakes you up
listen and you want to gamble put an ice
cube there i don't give a [ __ ] what you
do whatever gets you started plain and
simple hello tushy is a rebel
revolutionary
new bidet that attaches right to your
toilet no muss no fuss no nothing they
have a 90-day guarantee
in case something happens but nothing's
going to happen if they can carry my fat
ass they'll do wonders for you a nice
clean [ __ ] but again why have a clean
[ __ ] why sit in a dirty chair all day
and you're developing bacteria and
hemorrhoids you don't need that you know
what hello tush is here to help you go
to hellotissue.com and press in church
bam and get 10 off your order right to
your house who's better than you you're
going to feel more confident your balls
are going to be clean you're going to
thank me ladies this is it right now
everybody wants to have a baby but you
want to have a you want to walk around
with a wounded skunk this is your chance
right now to go to hellotushy.com and
keep that whole area clean it's the
summertime you don't want to slip up now
this is how you start getting christmas
presents you understand me you got to
have the monkey ready
in the summertime that's right
that's right a little hello
hellotushy.com right now press it hit it
lee
bam all right
i want to thank quip one more time and i
want to thank naturebox.com again
go to equip.com joey i want to thank my
brother brody stevens who i love yeah
different mother joey 1985 he was doing
comedy you got him with the [ __ ] comic
reader
who [ __ ] rest in peace we stole her
valiums downstairs and we used to eat a
pizza she put her penis in a pickle jar
and she put a penis in a pickle joint
she used to say who ate my potato chips
or whatever the [ __ ] it was that was a
good tomorrow night [ __ ] bring an
improv next thursday [ __ ] you
know what i'm working out
the ice house pasadena 8 30 the 15th
i'll see you [ __ ] there have a
phenomenal weekend stay black uncle joey
loves you yes
[Music]
you